Õpetaja: Kogu aeg.
Õpetaja: Kuidas kas automaatide arv peab? Olema Üks või avatase?
Õpetaja: Jah, Sest seal on nagu mõeldud seda, et minimaalselt Sul peabki olema vähemalt üks automaat, et muidu nagu on see, et ei, siin on pangaautomaadi Asukoht Siin on automaadid, teenused, aga pole ühtegi automaati. Jah,
Õpetaja: jah. Ee, see. See on lihtsalt niiöelda. Ütleme siis äriline valik. Vaata, et me soovime, niimoodi, et kasutaja saab aru, Vaata, et Noh, üks on miinimum,
Õpetaja: kui ta nüüd ise läheb. Esiteks, seal, mis me Frontis tegime, siis me panime sinna Html Ile juurde, et miinimum Ongi üks onju, et neid nuppe vajutada. Seda näiteks ee. Allapoole ei saagi minna. Küll saab ta selle üle trükkida
Õpetaja: ja ja kui ta väiksemaks väärtuseks, Siis tuleb see kontroll. Nii et ütleb, et vähemalt üks peab olema. See on kaine nagu mugavuse asi, Vaata, et, ee, põhimõtteliselt Sealt sealt saad nagu alustada, et üks on niikuinii miinimum,
Õpetaja: Aga, noh, päriselus oleks ka siis jälle nagu, Ee, Ütleme siis selle
Õpetaja: äripoole, nagu otsustada. Vaata, et milline see kasutajakogemus peaks olema. On ju, et Kas seal on see eeltäidetud või Ei ole? On ju,
Õpetaja: et ee, et Suures pildis. Ee, on Jah, Põhimõtteliselt ütleme siis kasutaja kogemust mõjutav,
Õpetaja: aga tehniliselt võiks selle sealt täiesti vabalt ka eemaldada. Kui kui seda sooviks, Et selles mõttes see poleks ee. Kuidagi probleem
Õpetaja: Ee. Panen frondi käima. Kas ma Screenshare üldse
Õpetaja: Okei Ee, teen. Siis tegin lahti, Ee, panin käima Front I
Õpetaja: et oleks, midagi näha. See üksteist haru on veel ees. Ahaa, ee, to do on. Noh, vaata, kui on hea kui Paned eelmisest päevast mingi to do ee. Päris tehtud veel ei ole, et siin on mõned punktid, et, ee,
Õpetaja: kaua kui see analüüsib selle projekti sinna alla, ära. Siis ta muutub niiöelda värvilisemaks. Aga et, ee, mitte admin kasutajale.
Õpetaja: Kasutaja tuleb lehele urli abil. Ahah See on nüüd Siis see mõte, et. Ee, kui mina niiöelda teen. Ee, teen korra fronti lahti.
Õpetaja: Noh, ee, kaua see server siin käivitub?
Õpetaja: Nüüd juba peaks vastu üleval olema tuleb,
Õpetaja: et, ee, kui ei ole sisse logitud. Aga tuleks lihtsalt kaldkriips location.
Õpetaja: Siis hetkel tuleb meil see vaade ette, mis, Sest et me pole isegi sisse loginud. Meil pole seda linkigi siin nähtaval. Me pole Admin Sellega siis peakski tegelema, et ee, et ei saaks niukest asja näha.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis, millest võiks alustada, on see, et plaan on selline, et kui. Et mis juhtub, siis kui kasutaja paneb selle võrli sisse. Mida ta siis nägema peaks? Ee, mina pakun välja, et me teeme eraldi lehe. Nagu näiteks
Õpetaja: eraldi Vaatajad,
Õpetaja: et, noh kasutaja, Kes selle urli paneb? Ta tuleb meie serverisse. Üks variant oleks näidata talle page. Not found I aa. See oleks ka võimalus, aga ee, Pigem nagu,
Õpetaja: ee. Ma nagu näitaks midagi spetsiifilisemat, et nagu, okei, et sul ei ole nagu niukest luba. See on nagu jälle ka arhitektuuriline valik. Vaata, et mida kasutaja nagu näeb. Ee, kui ta läheb niuksele lehele,
Õpetaja: kuhu tal ei ole ligipääsu. Ee, Meie võiksime siis teha uue Lehe,
Õpetaja: No millest alustame? Kui on uus vaade. Uus leht
Õpetaja: Usalla New Component Kohe, kui ta sealt lahti teeb.
Õpetaja: You component no panekski siis Näiteks not Outdoor ised. Midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Taskis seda kirjas polnud, aga me ei tee enam
Õpetaja: vaik. Siin on mingid näpp puudu.
Õpetaja: Vist peaks kirjapildis Morless olema õige.
Õpetaja: Elasin kõigest peaaegu kümme aastat inglismaal. Onju, aga? Inglise keel ikka valmistab veel ee raskusi ja küsimärke
Õpetaja: Nii ee. No, kui Me hakkame mingit uut vaadet tegema. Siis millest võiks üldse alustada?
Õpetaja: Meil on üks oma kindel süsteem. Kuidas me niiöelda
Õpetaja: ee, asju niiöelda visuaalpoole peal majandame.
Õpetaja: Mis me sealt Food Trap ist tahame.
Õpetaja: Ja seda sama asja, mis ee panime endale shortcut alla, et et mida iganes me Siia joonistame, et, ee. Sooviksime kindlasti nagu kontrollida seda, et kuidas see ruumiline paigutus on?
Õpetaja: Ehk. Siis, ee. Tuleme. Paneme siia konteineri.
Õpetaja: Ee, vana Hea konteiner. Ee, üks rohu. Kaks, kolm, Nii
Õpetaja: tõepoolest. Step by step. Seda pildida siis. Ee, nüüd. Järgmine asi oleks siis see, et meil On vaja nagu manageerida seda, et kuidas. Nagu see reaktiivsus on niiöelda, et millal seda asja nagu näidatakse, Millest ma siin räägin,
Õpetaja: et meil On nagu küsimus, et millal seda näidatakse. Kus me seda saame niiöelda sätestada või
Õpetaja: kus me saame, Nagu seda kontrollida, et millal seda vaadet üldse nagu idee järgi. Browser kuvaks
Õpetaja: läbi ruutidefinitsiooni Ehk me läheme Ruuteri indeksisse.
Õpetaja: Noh, sa ütlesid päris hästi selle läbi ruuti Definitsiooni, sest täpselt Need asjad nad ongi. Näed ruut Mitmesest.
Õpetaja: Ee, siit pead otsima. Kui Seda pole juba teinud.
Õpetaja: Ja kohe. See esimene rida Siin ongi Vaata, System.
Õpetaja: Siin on nagu see näide.
Õpetaja: Said selle nupu kah?
Õpetaja: No Vaadake, siin ongi. Siin on massiiv ruutide definitsioonidest
Õpetaja: et, see, ee, kui me Vaatame korra pulli pärast Ka selle tagasi, onju? Panen korra selle kinni.
Õpetaja: Siin on tavaline. Jaava script. Konst Ruuter võrdub,
Õpetaja: kui sa kutsud välja Mingi meetodi, mis midagi tagastab. Ja sa soovid sellega midagi edasi teha,
Õpetaja: Siis pane see muutujasse. Näete, see on objekt.
Õpetaja: On objekt et siin, Nagu selles mõttes, et ta on eriline objekt. Siin ongi nagu mingi voe enda mingi meetod. Mis siis, ee, loob üldse nagu mingi ruuteri Ja See ruuter.
Õpetaja: See lehekülgede ruuter. Nüüd siis asubki siin.
Õpetaja: Me tahame teha juurde ühe. Definitsiooni. Lähme lihtsalt sinna alla.
Õpetaja: Võtame
Õpetaja: kõik need read Ja ühe niiöelda reavahetuse. Ka. Mul läks nüüd valesti Natukene. Vaata, ma oleks tahtnud kogemata võtta seda ka
Õpetaja: natukene Täpsemalt tuleb siin jälgida.
Õpetaja: Kontroll D.
Õpetaja: Kuskil midagi punaseks ei läinud. Siis süntaks katki Ei, lähe. Kui üks koma on puudu, kohe katki ei näe. Viga
Õpetaja: iga viga, iga Kaks viga, Nii, ee.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis on vaja mingisugune rada öelda. Välja Mõelda võib siis lihtsalt öelda. Not outdoor ised, midagi taolist,
Õpetaja: Ma korra Teen selle komponendi selle pealt. Saan kopida nime ka.
Õpetaja: Nato Guys Two N A. B.
Õpetaja: Ju võibolla. On Vaja veits kirjutada et, ta praegu Pakkus seal mingit muud jama, mida ma ei taha. Vaata, põhimõtteliselt see, mis mina kirjutasin, siis siin all, on näha siniste tähemärkidega, et miks ta nagu. Miks ta pakub mulle sellist asja? Miks ta arvab? Vaata, ma tahan.
Õpetaja: See klapib nende tähtedega, Mis mina olen kirjutanud, siis sa Arvad, et äkki sa tahad niukest asja?
Õpetaja: Natuke Läks kogemata sealt mööda.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi valin selle.
Õpetaja: Ee, see võiks siis olla Nato eest ruut, aga Päikse väega.
Õpetaja: Noh, kuidas ma saaksin nüüd proovida seda, et, ee. Kas tõesti avaneb mul siis? Ee, põhimõtteliselt see vaade, kus on lihtsalt kolmkolomeetrit
Õpetaja: Saaksin proovida, et. Kas see töötab
Õpetaja: kaasa? Lihtsalt testida, et kui ma võtan selle sama orli siit kopin ee meie niiöelda veebilehele
Õpetaja: ma panen Selle Location I asemel tuleb see kolm kolonit.
Õpetaja: Tundub, et töötab, onju?
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, mida võiksin teha?
Õpetaja: Ee, siia esimese võiks jääda põhimõtteliselt üks Rou üks, kolm. Ma pakun
Õpetaja: siia sisse. Võiks. Nüüd. Ee, see veergu võiks teha näiteks Headeri A üks ja panna liigipääs ja elatus.
Õpetaja: Noh, See tekst on jälle nagu,
Õpetaja: Noh, paneme mingi sellise asja ka. Võibolla.
Õpetaja: Aa, ah? Mis emotika on? See on
Õpetaja: veel väljas. Jah, ee, võibolla siis teha natukene.
Õpetaja: Tegelikult saaks ka päris nagu emotika olema. Ma praegu peas kohe ei teagi, kuidas saaks ikoone. Ee, meil on nüüd see Fosfor
Õpetaja: Fosfor Icons on näiteks, ee, kus võib midagi leida. Noh, võibolla ma vaatan ka siit ka mingit.
Õpetaja: Oh, aga ta ütleb, ma, mõtlesin et ma saingi Vaata täpselt. Õige asja. Aga see on hoopis noor. Neil on ka mõte. Vaata, et kui midagi ei leia, vaata, et mis? Siis nagu on, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, jah, see on motika. One ka üldse. Vaatame korra. Motika on ei ole huvitav.
Õpetaja: Visake meid
Õpetaja: tervist, hüvit Oi, noh, näiteks see kohe käit.
Õpetaja: Multsid saaks valida. Näiteks siis ue.
Õpetaja: Ta annab kohe siis ikooni, mis võiks justkui töötada,
Õpetaja: Oota, mis ta on? Kutsub lihtsalt välja komponente.
Õpetaja: Saate aru? Sa lihtsalt deegina kaasas. Keegi on selle koodi kirjutanud. Noh, mis? Keegi nemad ongi kirjutanud, kes iganes
Õpetaja: See Organisatsioon või ettevõte on tasuta kaupa. On See käiks
Õpetaja: võtan? Selle siit see. On nupp ka võibolla. Panna selle siia
Õpetaja: ma. Ei tea Kas ka selle sisse äkki või sisse panna?
Õpetaja: Sa ei taha niimoodi. Ma panen pigem niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Siis ta ütleb, et talle ei meeldi nak Importajad.
Õpetaja: Noh, aga import? Siis Import tegi siia impordi.
Õpetaja: Tegijaid siin. Kasutatakse seda komponente vaadata, kuidas ta siis välja näeb,
Õpetaja: Kas on ka lihtsalt otsa panna juhuslikult ja tohin siia sisse panna midagi laadist.
Õpetaja: Võibolla paneme siis. Ma ei tea natuke suuremaks.
Õpetaja: Tahaks mingit värvi anda sellele näiteks, Ee, prooviks korra. Kas ma sellega saaks anda talle?
Õpetaja: Ee, mis need värvid on? Mingid sekundäärid.
Õpetaja: Background Core Color Secondary keelatud on, on Danger,
Õpetaja: Vaata, mis ta pakub. Ma pole niimoodi sellisel kujul nagu mixinud.
Õpetaja: Border. Danger. Äkki sa teed mingi. Ei, vaatame korra kui paneks Bg,
Õpetaja: kas Niimoodi saab suvaliste asjadega. Noh, saab background Colorate, palun väga.
Õpetaja: Aga see võibolla ei ole nagu nii
Õpetaja: onju ee. Võibolla on midagi huvitavamat, otsiks Mõne Gif I hoopis näiteks. Ee, Access
Õpetaja: Teina neid kihv oma piltide all.
Õpetaja: Noh, et mis see on?
Õpetaja: Noh, mhmh. Sobib.
Õpetaja: Oi, ee tahab vaadata, kuidas saab niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, copy. Image adres.
Õpetaja: Aga see nüüd ei pruugi päris olla. Ma kõigepealt vaatan ka ära, kuhu ta läheb, Tundub, et on õige, Aga minule sobib,
Õpetaja: et ee. Tulla siia. Ee, panna siia. Samma Colli sisse. Veel midagi?
Õpetaja: Ee, mis meil on vaja. Meil On vaja pilti.
Õpetaja: Image.
Õpetaja: Siin tasub valida see image source. Natukene kätte. Ka. Image source ja variant. Siit, ee.
Õpetaja: Võtame see tajt. No ma Ei, viitsi et pimedat seda ei näe. Ma võin panna.
Õpetaja: Oota, paneme ka pilti. See kirjutad, mis siin pildil olema peaksid?
Õpetaja: Pingviinid kaklevad.
Õpetaja: Nii Pääs keelatud.
Õpetaja: Mäletame korra. Kui pilte ennast sisu pole,
Õpetaja: siis katkine ikoon. Pingviinid kaklevad ligipääs keelatud, Aga kui sors I alla panna see pilt siis on.
Õpetaja: No võiks olla võibolla suurem, aga savis, Jah, Võibolla class ee panna ka class.
Õpetaja: Ee, on ka mingid pildi asjad Image fluid, Vist on see põhiline. Neil, Ma ei tea, kas sellest pilt läheb suuremaks väiksemaks. Ekraanipilt?
Õpetaja: Noh, ma ei tea midagi taolist, aga nüüd on mõte Siis see, et meil on vaja siis teha niimoodi, et kui keegi üritab tulla
Õpetaja: Location vaatele, ilma et ta oleks sisse loginud, siis Ta peaks viima hoopis siia, Nato. Tore, just.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis ta niimoodi?
Õpetaja: Kas vist aitas mingit vana asja midagi taolist?
Õpetaja: Okei, päev, korra üheksa Komitee.
Õpetaja: Tegin siin suht kiirelt Kas keegi tahab järgi tulla? Davai selle Push I
Õpetaja: ning samal ajal, kui te tulete siin vaikselt, järgi, siis Lihtsalt ee mõttekoht.
Õpetaja: Kui me läheme korra siia Location i alla, et
Õpetaja: et kus võiks olla see koht, kus me peaksime alustama, et kui Me tahame kontrollida seda, et kas sul on ligipääs või mitte Ja siis suunata kasutaja mujale.
Õpetaja: Kui me mõtleme, nagu, et kus kohast nagu See action võiks nagu saada alguse kus kohast. Kuidas me. Sa. Kuidas me printsiibis saame? Sellist asja saavutada, et me hakkame vaatama? Sa oled Sisse logitud või mitte. Ja siis, ee. Käivitame selle tegevuse, et. Ee. Kuule, mine tee selle lehele.
Õpetaja: Before Mountain, onju, et kui lehele ju Nagu maandud.
Õpetaja: No siis Before. Mount Aa käivitub
Õpetaja: No before Mount You võiks olla see koht, kus me siis hakkame vaatama. Programmiliselt, et kas sul on siia asja või mitte?
Õpetaja: No, kui me Scroll ime siia. Ee,
Õpetaja: Methods. Bloki Lõpu. Põhimõtteliselt tahan. Peale Metsachet, onju? Ma juba nägin korra seda method kinni panna.
Õpetaja: Hetkel Before Mount is on Get Cities Get location Transaction types.
Õpetaja: Siin. On Selline küsimus, et kas neid, kas neid tegevusi. Gat Citys ja Get Location Transaction types on üldse mõtet käivitada.
Õpetaja: Mm Okei, siis, ee. Kuna siin selles osas saab puhast koodi kirjutada? Siin. Ei, defineerime mingeid meetodeid. Need meetodid on üleval. On ju
Õpetaja: siis? Ee Mis asi peaks siia vahepeale tulema? Vaata, mis suunab niiöelda meie programmi käitumist.
Õpetaja: Mingisugune If lause, on ju?
Õpetaja: Okei, mis meil sinna ifi sisse peab lõpuks minema. Puule on on ju
Õpetaja: Ee, Mis see Puule on? Milleks see puule on? Peab rehkenduma. Aa, millal ta peaks olema? True
Õpetaja: on Mingi kasutajaid. Või
Õpetaja: Ei, seda ei oleks vaja. Vaata, Noh, päeva. Lõpus ongi, et milline on asja sellele lehele? Vaata, on ju see, mis sa esimesena ütlesid, oli tegelikult õige.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis hakkame mõtlema, et kas meil võib ju kuskil midagi olemas olla? Mis võiks? Meid aidata? Et Nagu otsustada seda ära, et olevad mind või mitte,
Õpetaja: Kuhu me tegime tervisele?
Õpetaja: Ahhaa, see on Storage.
Õpetaja: Aga kui me räägime Session Storage ist, siis, ee, meie tegime mingit,
Õpetaja: ee, noh, session storage I kaudu saab vaadata. Aga kas me peame hakkama kisu kirjutama? Jälle koodi, et. Noh, mine vaata. Võta sealt Session Storage ist väärtus ja, Ee, vaata, et kas see võrdub Admin.
Õpetaja: Ahah, Vot nii õiget juttu. Räägid, et me ju tegime tegelikult teenuste alla sellise Nüüd hakkabki vaikselt tulema. Ka see nagu mugavus sisse. Vaata, et
Õpetaja: kuna me tegime Login Servicesis. Ee, kui me lahendasime, siis me tegime eraldi koha, vaata kus Me hoiame niukest kahte meetodit userist. Login
Õpetaja: User is admin.
Õpetaja: Sa vastad tõele, et kui kutsud need meetodid välja, siis see tagastables vastavalt sellele. Noh, useris. Adminiga vaadatakse, et Session Storage. Otsi sealt role name. Kui see nüüd rehkendub sealt ee, andmeid saades kätte Admin iks,
Õpetaja: siis Kas Admin World of Admin on truup.
Õpetaja: Kui ei võrdu, siis ei ole. Ehk siis sisuliselt See meetod aitaks meid vastutajale.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma tulen tagasi Siia Location use. Saan ma aru, et käitumist on vaja If lausega niiöelda mõjutada.
Õpetaja: Ee, teeme selle koodikeha siia. Valmis,
Õpetaja: Siis Mis ma siia sisse võiks kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Siia peab tulema, onju? Või? See selles mõttes tulema. Kui True on, siis sa oled admin ja siis läheb läheb seda Rada pidi.
Õpetaja: Else oleks see. Vaata, noh, ma kirjutan.
Õpetaja: Saada kasutaja.
Õpetaja: Oota, oota, raisk.
Õpetaja: See on meie plaan.
Õpetaja: Mis see, kuidas kui meil on Praegult siin meetod siin.
Õpetaja: Niukene meetod nagu User is admin, mis tagastab Ehk
Õpetaja: siis, kuidas me nüüd siis saaksime toimetada? Mis te mõtlete, on,
Õpetaja: Täpselt, et kui mina praegu kutsun välja koodilõigu, mis asub siinss Session, Storage Service.
Õpetaja: Kutsun sealt välja. Koodilõigu.
Õpetaja: User, is Admin paremal pool, mida Ta näitab, mis ta tagastab.
Õpetaja: Nii, kas ifi sisse peabki minema? Jah, ehk siis. Ja kas? Kas siin ütleme niimoodi? Kui see on true?
Õpetaja: Kas teeme niimoodi? Rainer
Õpetaja: enam ei tee? Naine lubab, et enam nii ei tee. Väga hea, seda mulle meeldiks nagu. Vaata oma lapsega. Vaata, et kui laps juba ütleb enam nii ei tee, siis Okei. Oleme jõudnud arusaamale,
Õpetaja: et miks ei ole seda vaja teha,
Õpetaja: sest ta juba Ise ongi true või False pole vaja.
Õpetaja: No kui user on Admin, siis tuleb kogu see osa, et see kogu muu muusika, Aga nüüd Ongi see, et Aga kui sa ei ole,
Õpetaja: siis tahaksime sulle öelda et mine kuskile mujale.
Õpetaja: Nüüd kuidas saab minna, Kuidas saab koodiliselt ta Niiöelda lükata. Kasutaja uuele.
Õpetaja: Vaatame
Õpetaja: Niukene asi nagu ruuter, mis on igal pool mujal niiöelda nähtav Seesama ruuter.
Õpetaja: Router Push Sellel objektil näete ruuter objektil. Ma ei tea, kas ma saan klikkida siia. See on rooter objekt.
Õpetaja: Nii, see on interface. Okei, see on põhimõtteliselt te võite mõelda Ka objekt. Ee, Ma ei ole kunagi seda proovinud. Aga kui siit vaadata, niuke asi, nagu panna see kinni
Õpetaja: siin, peaks nägema ka tegelikult Kuidagi mingi valemega. Kõike meetodeid. No ma saan siit otsida ka korra. Kontroll F ja Push.
Õpetaja: Ee, Paneme juba sulud ka.
Õpetaja: Kas on Niukene Meetod siin selles Router klassis nagu push,
Õpetaja: mis ootab sisse Meet niiöelda muutujat tsu
Õpetaja: ja siis vaatab nagu mingit objekti
Õpetaja: et, rooter Push Iga saame teha. Meil oleks võimalus tegelikult siis kohe siia siin öelda Router push ja siis hakata defineerima. Vaata, et kuhu on meid vaja lükata, Aga meil on nagu oma niiöelda süsteem ja arhitektuur ja lähenemine. Kuidas me tahame niiöelda sellist navigeerimist manageerida
Õpetaja: Me ei taha kirjutada ja meil Tegime sellise koha, kus kõik, igasugused Push Id saavad olema.
Õpetaja: No siia saakski siis teha uue meetodi Navigate ju No vot autorised ju, või et.
Õpetaja: Ja siis ütleme. Viitamegi, kui ma klikin selle ruuteri peal
Õpetaja: ta tuleb siia. Nad on omavahel seotud. Ruuter on Ruuteri indeksist, Nüüd ütlen Siin Bosch.
Õpetaja: Mida push ootab sisse?
Õpetaja: Noh, vihjeks on siis võt selle niiöelda sildi nimi või muuta nimi on two Aga, Kui me näeme Niukeste suurte tähtedega. Mingisuguse meenutab mingi nagu klassi nime või midagi taolist. Siis mida ta siia sisse ootab?
Õpetaja: Toyotast ringi Toyota siia numbreid Toyota siia pooleni. Mida ta ootab siis see siin
Õpetaja: minema.
Õpetaja: Puteri nime. Ta ei oota sisse.
Õpetaja: Jõuate ka sisse. Mida ta ootab sisse? Mida see on. See see on tüüp, mida ta ootab sisse. Kui te näete niukest asja
Õpetaja: objekti. See peab olema päris hea skriptiobjekt. Kuidas me saame väga lihtsa kirjaviisiga luua objekti.
Õpetaja: Jah, siin javas küttes see. Nii Töötab vanasti Oli niimoodi pidid. Tegema ee new
Õpetaja: New Object Ja siis hakkama väärtusi andma, onju? Ei, no more.
Õpetaja: Noh, seda ilmselt ammu pole, et niipea kui me peame loogiliselt sulud, siis ta loob objekti ja me Saame kohe anda väärtuse, et see on see võlu.
Õpetaja: Noh, nüüd siin objektil. Vaata see objekt nüüd. Ee, Selles mõttes peab Ee vastama sellele Root Location Role.
Õpetaja: No vaatame korra seda. Kas ma kuidagi seda saan? Niimoodi Control B sellele ei saaks klikkida kuidagi
Õpetaja: Location.
Õpetaja: Vau, et ta ei luba Brenool otsida. Vaatan, kas ta leiab kuskilt Ee, ülesse.
Õpetaja: Root Location Rao.
Õpetaja: Näete, Niukene Objekt on olemas. Niukene tüüp.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tema sees Peaks olema igasugused väljad ja üks nendest peaks olema.
Õpetaja: Oota, ma pean siit otsida.
Õpetaja: Aa
Õpetaja: on. Bush On neid selle sellel objektil Kainda peavad olema siis teatud väljad.
Õpetaja: Kui me kontroll tühiks, siis meid aidatakse ka. Vaata, kõik niuksed väljad.
Õpetaja: Meid ei huvita see paah paaht on see, et ta on otserada. Vaata, kaldkriips.
Õpetaja: Ee, ruut, mis oli meil not autorised.
Õpetaja: Mis iganes võidame pigem kasutada nime sellepärast, et
Õpetaja: kui meie Push Ime ennast niiöelda nende nimede abil.
Õpetaja: Siis
Õpetaja: juhul, kui see rada mingil põhjusel peaks varem või hiljem muutuma, siis nimi jääb ikka samaks, et Meil on ainult üks koht, kus me defineerime rajad. Mitte nagu üle koodifaasi. Pilla valla laiali.
Õpetaja: Väga Väga hea on niimoodi teha.
Õpetaja: Ütleme, nimi on? Siis mis? See nimi oli?
Õpetaja: Päris Niukene Pikk. See on Niukene Kopi koht. Nagu põhimõtteliselt. Et ei tahaks vähemalt päris elus.
Õpetaja: Seda tahaks Kindlasti Copy Based. Ida vältida vigu
Õpetaja: üleüldiselt. Ma. Kui ma teen niukseid asju, kus mul on mingid asjad defineeritud ja ee on seal mingi asjad Siis ma kindlas mõttes. Mina alati. Ma ei hakka nagu üldse seal midagi kirjutama.
Õpetaja: Ee, lihtsalt vältida. Vigu sees piisab ainult ühest väiksest, Ee, näpuliigutusest ja tähelepanematusest. Ja kuskilt tuleb viga Lihtsam On see Copy Fastada?
Õpetaja: No nüüd on meil olemas selline meetod.
Õpetaja: Väga hea, me siis. Saame tagasi minna oma Location View Sse
Õpetaja: Location New Enter, tulen tagasi siia.
Õpetaja: Oleme siin kenasti before.
Õpetaja: No, kui me selle Navigation Service alla Tegime selle koodiploki, mida meil on vaja. Kuidas me saame talle ligi?
Õpetaja: Saab sellele asjale ligi.
Õpetaja: Sa kirjutad Navigation Service, et seal sees on Mingid ee, meetodid punktiga saab meetodeid välja kutsuda.
Õpetaja: Mind huvitab see.
Õpetaja: Noh, kenasti Keegi tuleb, loeb seda koodifaili. Tegelikult ta peaks suures pildis aru saama, Mis selle,
Õpetaja: kui nad vaatab Before Mountain.
Õpetaja: Ma isegi ei tea. Vaata, kas ma olen alati pannud sinna.
Õpetaja: Tegelikult hakkaks mõtlema, et, ee, Ma isegi tõstaks selle ülesse poole.
Õpetaja: Paneks selle before niimoodi siia kokku. Miks,
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et kui inimene tuleb siit niimoodi ülevalt, hakkab lugema, näiteks seda asja et, noh, neid importida niikuinii ei loo. Need võib. Impordid võib siin kõik niimoodi kokku tõmmata.
Õpetaja: Seda kedagi ei huvita tuleb vaatab, Ahah, komponendidanger. Ee, datablokis on Ee. Sellised muutujad.
Õpetaja: Blokis on lihtsalt niivõrd palju sisu before. On Tegelikult oluliselt ee lühem.
Õpetaja: Ma isegi. Lausa mõtleks niimoodi, et isegi enne seda data blokki võtaks selle before kohe siia peale.
Õpetaja: Seal oli kõige mõistlikum niimoodi siis. Copida Vaata. Ja vaata et, Ee, ma kohe võtan tagasi selle, et panna need lihtsalt kinni.
Õpetaja: Tuled kuskile siia reale. Vajutad kontrolliks. Ta võtab kogu selle koodiploki Tuled siia alla.
Õpetaja: Neid Hääli peab ka tegema. Kas te tegite juba selle liigutuse
Õpetaja: Kui ei ole veel teinud siis ma tahan seda häält kuulda.
Õpetaja: Mm, Paneme selle siia.
Õpetaja: Ma olen keegi. Just. Panin.
Õpetaja: Ee, et see tundub isegi loogilisem koht, kuhu before panna. Ma pole. Ma lihtsalt. Olen. Alati Olen kuidagi jõudnud niimoodi et sa juba teed nii palju Action It. Ära vaata siis. Okei, Aga nüüd on meil vaja midagi kontrollida, et Käivita ja nii edasi,
Õpetaja: et see ju tegelikult oleks kohe informatsioon. Vaata, et enne kui ma hakkan üldse vaatama, et mis siin toimub nagu,
Õpetaja: Ahaa, et kui. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, user is admin. Noh, ma loeksin seda. Mul sellest objektist on kama Kui user on admin. Vabandust, Ma telefon Ka enam ma igaks juhuks võtan vastu.
Õpetaja: Ja hallo,
Õpetaja: tere.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: Mhmh.
Õpetaja: Noh, sobib.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: aga kas siis ma. Ma toon tagasihoota,
Õpetaja: kui Kui jõuab, siis jõuad. Kui ei jõua, siis toon tagasi.
Õpetaja: Aga selge.
Õpetaja: Mhmh.
Õpetaja: Ja. No ma tulen niikuinii selles mõttes autole järgi, et kui saab, siis on super. Ja kui ei saa, siis Ee. Vaatame Järgmisel nädalal
Õpetaja: teeme niimoodi. Aitäh, Vabandust, auto mul siin pärandis väikene
Õpetaja: sos auto Ise Vana Fiet. Ee, vajades
Õpetaja: kolm.
Õpetaja: Siis oleks kuskil midagi valesti selles mõttes, et, ee, mingi
Õpetaja: ee loogiline sulg. Ee, koma. Mida iganes on tegelikult valetada. Kui leiab palju vigu, Võibolla ei saa
Õpetaja: iga. Iga. Aa, nüüd teeme niimoodi. Iga kord kui keegi soovib. Kui mitte, siis peab ütlema.
Õpetaja: Davai pushind või?
Õpetaja: Aa, Mhm.
Õpetaja: Push on tehtud. Mis teha saab? Ee, mis see liigutus võiks olla? On Control set control set Seni kaua, kuni tundub, et on korras.
Õpetaja: Mm, paar eelmist asja nagu seal külje peal. Näiteks lihtsalt, et sa ei oska.
Õpetaja: Näitas neid eelmiseid samme eelmiseid samme.
Õpetaja: Ma pakun, et äkki. Kui ma tegin ripande lahti, otsisin midagi
Õpetaja: Ee, siin. Kui näiteks nägin, mingeid valikuid samamoodi Niimoodi väga ei mõelnud tagasi minema selle peale
Õpetaja: Aa tagasi minemise peal. Aa, ma tegin. Control tab seda.
Õpetaja: Vot see käis nii kiirelt. Vaata, et äkki seda mõtled. Okei? No siis teine kord. Kui näed, siis hüüa kohe vahele. Vaata, kuidas teed seda.
Õpetaja: Kuulge, ma tegin bussi. Tehke nüüd ja tulge järgi.
Õpetaja: Ee, inimene.
Õpetaja: Aga praegu on see, et sa oled üldse mingil põhjusel minu aru.
Õpetaja: Vaatame korra nagu komeedialt seda muudatusi
Õpetaja: siin midagi vaatama ei ole. Aa. Noh, siin on nagu see, et sa teinud seda Push I teha, aga peaks ikkagi tegema niimoodi sealt ära
Õpetaja: ja
Õpetaja: jah, eks? Mm, Ja siis telefons.
Õpetaja: Ee Niiöelda paralleelselt.
Õpetaja: Kui meil on praegu see niiöelda siis on niimoodi, et need punkt E. Trach,
Õpetaja: kui seda vaadata. Et Ee, kuidas on. Pärin ajalugu.
Õpetaja: Sa ei pea omavalt ära minema,
Õpetaja: Aga see on nagu fail. On ka nagu paremoodi alt vaadata, Sellepärast
Õpetaja: tema näitab, et see on just ka ära kustutatud. Las ta on nagu asemele pannud
Õpetaja: sõidulaudega.
Õpetaja: Aga nad on igal suured.
Õpetaja: Jah, ee, Nii, ee, aga igal juhul sa peaks nüüd töötama. Saab ju kohe proovida ka.
Õpetaja: Ma olen näiteks pangaautomaadid vaatele või kuhu iganes. Ja nüüd Tulen, proovin seda Location vaadet.
Õpetaja: Siis ta ütleb kohe, et
Õpetaja: ei ole nagu lubatud, et ee, kindlasti. Noh, päris Production is ühel või teisel viisil peaks olema Niukene
Õpetaja: Ee, kaitse peal.
Õpetaja: Need vaated, mis ei ole teatud rollidel, et ei oleks kuidagi. Ütleme lihtsalt urliga manipuleeritavad Ee, ja Et loomulikult see eeldab seda, et pahalane nii või naa, peaks ka teadma neid urle, kuhu proovida minna
Õpetaja: aga, noh, ma arvan, et ee, Ühel või teisel viisil on kuidagi ikka võimalik informatsiooni kätte saada, et siis mitte teha seda kuidagi lihtsaks. No turvalisus on üldse Niukene eraldi Täiesti eraldi teema. Ja. Ja.
Õpetaja: Ja maailm. Ee, et, ee. Noh, ma arvan, et see on ka asi, mis tegelikult läheb ajas järjest tähtsamaks,
Õpetaja: Eriti nüüd, sellel Ai ajastul, kus väga palju koodi niiöelda siis tehaksegi Ai abil.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis on päris suur tõenäosus, et seal võib olla Igasuguseid probleeme, mis Nagu ee,
Õpetaja: pahalastele annab, siis nagu mingid uued ee ründe vektorid.
Õpetaja: Noh, siin ju tegelt veidi aega tagasi oli ka ju Ma ei tea, mis sellest saanud on. Ee, näiteks Cloudil on oma mudel mütos. Mis siis ongi? Nagu kuidagi spetsialiseerunud sellele, et ta leiab turvaauke eesmärgiga mitte sisse murda. Loomulikult vaid, et neid üles leida. Ja siis on võimalik neid parandada.
Õpetaja: Nad selle mudeli tegid Ee, nad said aru, et see on mingi väga hullult võimekas asi.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis selle roll out on olnud ka selline, et on ainult valitud organisatsioonidele ettevõtetele
Õpetaja: Ee, riikidele antud selle jaoks nagu ligipääs, et tavaliselt inimesed ei saagi sellele ligi.
Õpetaja: Ee, eks nad mingi hetk Varem või hiljem ka need mudelid kuidagi ühel või teisel viisil avaldavad. Aga see on nagu veits keeruline neile, et nagu näen. Vaata, et see on mõeldud selle jaoks, Et kõik saaksid siis nagu kasutada seda mudelit ja, ee, lappida oma mingi programme ja asju.
Õpetaja: Aga kuidas sa teed seda nagu paralleelselt, Vaata, et Annad nagu ee, ettevõtetel võimaluse leida turvaauke. Noh, ega pättidel on ikkagi nagu Selle võrra on keerulisem, et vaata, et neil ei ole koodibaasi,
Õpetaja: et nemad peavad ikkagi nagu sisse murdma. Nagu nagu päris sisse murdma,
Õpetaja: et ee, et ettevõttel või organisatsioonil või inimesel mis, iganes on Ikkagi ligipääs Source, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga jah, et see Niukene. Noh, ma ütlen, et ega väga täpselt ei tea.
Õpetaja: Ee, mismoodi, aga tegelikult on juba juttu olnud. Sellest ka, et ai abil juba tehaksegi igast häkkimisi. Asju
Õpetaja: Siiani on pät olnud inimene, aga nüüd tuli ai tõuke neid kuskilt,
Õpetaja: No jah, eks Seal aidaga on ka jälle ikkagi inimene. Vaata onju, et et eks see, eks? See on kogu aeg olnud see kassihiire mäng. Ja see ei lõppegi kunagi. Tegelikult mitte kunagi. See otse ei saa.
Õpetaja: Ee, et, ee. Kogu aeg on suur mass. Ee, pahaseid inimesi, Kes üritavad siis ee leida võimalusi ühel või teisel viisil see kuidagi rahaks muidugi keerata. Mis ikka tehakse. Seda tehakse ka lihtsalt sellepärast, et ollakse pahane. Ja ehk siis on ka
Õpetaja: ee, niiöelda riigi riigiti seda värki, et. Ee, noh, teame ju. Vaata, et ee,
Õpetaja: suurtel riikidel kindlasti Kõikidel on oma mingisuguse häkkerite armee, Kes siis toimetab ja spioneerib. Ja mida iganes, et, ee, see see asi ei söö kunagi, otsa
Õpetaja: See Võitlus on Niukene. Ee, igipõline võitlus. Ma ei usu, et isegi tuhande aasta pärast mitte midagi. Selles mõttes, nagu oleks muutunud,
Õpetaja: et ee ikka On kindlasti see sama asi, et, ee, ühe ühel poolel on, ee, osapool, kes üritab asju hoida niimoodi, et keegi sisse ei saa ja teine Teisel pool on osapool, kes üritab sisse saada, et see see näitab,
Õpetaja: ma arvan.
Õpetaja: No meil on siis mingi elementaarne kaitse olemas
Õpetaja: Ee, Mingi duduu oli meil veel seal all. Ega see nüüd ometi kaduma ei läinud? Mm,
Õpetaja: kus ta meil oli?
Õpetaja: Ta oli kirjutatud kuskile, siia, Mitte admin kasutada. Tuleb lehele selle saime korda.
Õpetaja: Need on meetrite järjekord. Ee, seda võiks natukene mujal ka vaadata. Nüüd õudsalt tahaks niimoodi, et ei tee seda trikki, et kui mina löön, ee, nagu tühjasid, ridusid, tema nagu pressib vahele,
Õpetaja: et ma mõtlen seda, et mingi hetk ta Kuidagi kogu aeg tõmbab neid kokku, on nii?
Õpetaja: Ee, Siis teeks sellise triki. Kuidas ma vanasti tegin? Asju oli niimoodi, et, ee,
Õpetaja: mõtleme nagu, Et Mis on nagu kõige ee loogilisemad meetodid. Mis Kõige, kõige esimesena niiöelda käivituvad. Või on kõige tähtsamad
Õpetaja: minu vaatevinklist siin Kõige tähtsam meetod on Ee adlocation. Sest et see on ainukene meetod mis käivitatakse nupuga,
Õpetaja: et, ee, ma nagu tahaks panna selle kohe kõige ette,
Õpetaja: aga teistpidi Võiks muidugi mõelda, et kui kasutaja Ee logib niiöelda, saab siia lehele tulla, siis esimesena asjana käivitatakse. Ja mõte on lihtsalt selles. Vaata, kuidas, Nagu enda jaoks valida mingisugust ee lähenemist, kus kogu aeg kuidagi mingi järjekord on sama.
Õpetaja: Ee, et siin Võibolla siis nagu mõelda niimoodi, et Et vahet pole, nagu. Et kas. Kas midagi saab klikkida. On Alati eespool või midagi saab midagi. Alati laetakse esmajärjekorras, mis iganes stiili valitsus võiks sellele kindlaks jääda.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd see järjekord ei ole nüüd nagu selles mõttes monster. Tähtis, et see mingi kuskil kohas mingi nagu meetodite Järjekord ei ole nagu päris nagu sama, mis niiöelda väljakutsumisel. Niiöelda aset leiab. Hea on see kui nagu suures pildis on asjad nagu enamvähem järjekorras,
Õpetaja: et. Ee, ma arvan, et ka nagu midagi väga tagasi ei Tuleks. Kuigi võibki olla niuke väga. Ütleme siis niiöelda anaalne nende järjekordadega, Nii et talle meeldiks, et kõik oleks ilusti järjekorras
Õpetaja: vaja.
Õpetaja: See ei ole nagu sellised lahe põhjus.
Õpetaja: No see on ettevõtte kultuur jälle, vaata, Et kas ee. Neil on nagu mingisugused reeglid ja kokkulepped, mis on kuidagi kirjalikult viis nagu kirjas, on ju
Õpetaja: Või on siis see kandida Niimoodi, et, ee, et on nagu mingisugused kokkulepped ja kirjaviisid, mis nagu ei ole, nagu kuidagi kirjalikult kokku lepitud, aga lihtsalt koodibaasi järgi on nagu, näha, et et nii on. Vaata,
Õpetaja: et. Noh, Lhv S. Keegi mulle kunagi ei öelnud, Vaata, et mis järjekorras mingisuguses ülevalmuutujaid panna või Kuidas meetodid peaksid olema? Aga kui sa vaatad? Ticketil, ei ole niukest detailsust, et kui räägime räägime korra tiketitest ka
Õpetaja: tiketitega, nüüd niimoodi, vaata Et, Ee,
Õpetaja: ee. Te hakkate nägema. No see on jälle ka kõik. Sõltub ettevõtte kultuurist.
Õpetaja: Ee ja tabadest. Ee, ressurssidest ajast.
Õpetaja: Ee, ja nüüd Kõige lõpus. See sõltub inimestest.
Õpetaja: Ee, s ee. Mina nägin kahte tüüpi tigeteid
Õpetaja: Ee, olid, Ee, põhimõtteliselt nagu ma kutsun oneliner Id
Õpetaja: põhimõtteliselt ongi Nagu pealkiri. Ja siis on Description Is On mingisugune Paar sõna. Nagu põhimõtteliselt ritta seotud. Võibolla paar lauset. Päris onelinerit Nägin ka nagu Ee Ja Siis nägin niukseid. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, mis Ee, Ee, niuksed. Taastad, mis võivad hästi detailselt lahti keeratud, väga detailselt,
Õpetaja: pildid, asjad ja mingid skeemid Ja Ja nii edasi. No ma rääkisin ka sellest ühest taskist, kus oli nagu. Niimoodi et task ise oli keeruline ja veel läks kuskile Ja
Õpetaja: võisid vaba. Vabad käed võisid. Pingviin neid ee tippe panna. Kuhu saatsid? Ee, no seda Ei, Seda niukest asja. Kindlasti.
Õpetaja: Kuidas need raamid Või kuidas see lähteülesanne on, et. Ee,
Õpetaja: ei, see. Noh, ma üritangi sinna jõuda. Vaata, et mingisugused nagu sellisel kujul nagu meil need on siin, et tee selle nimeline komponent ja asi seda ei, ole, seda ei ole. See on arendaja. Niiöelda enda loomingus. Tema vaatab sinna sisse, Tema otsustab mis see kõige parem nimi on. Ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Küll on nagu. Noh, mis? Kindlalt on Näiteks kokku lepitud on, kui me Räägime. Ee, nüüd. Nagu nendest lepingulistest asjadest. Selles mõttes. Vaata, et meil on mingi teenus, mille me defineerime. Vaat see on seal olemas
Õpetaja: see, Et pingviinipilti panna. See, kui see oleks, See oleks seal ka olemas. Et kui me tahame, vaadata on ju.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga mida seal nagu, Noh, mida seal kindlasti nagu ei ole olemas, ongi siis see. Vaata, et kuhu sa paned failid. Kuidas sa nimetad meetodeid, Mida, nagu sellist detailsust kunagi ei ole.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tulen nüüd selle sama jutu juurde tagasi. Vaata, et ma nägin kahte erinevat tüüpi. Niiöelda taaske, vaata, kas Siis väga põhjalikud. Ee ja. Ja või siis versus nagu mingid onelinerid. Ee, siis ma arvan, et see on Niukene asi, mis juhtub peaaegu Igal pool, välja arvatud. Kui ongi kuskil nagu pigem nagu kultuur, et ma ei tea. Me teeme ikkagi nagu taaske ka korrektselt.
Õpetaja: Ma küsin teie käest. Ee, mis te arvate? Ee, kumb tavaliselt kirjutas paremaid. Ee, taaskä. Kas vana kogenud ee proff või ee. Uus algaja.
Õpetaja: Miks uus Algaja
Õpetaja: Viid siis tegeleda Sellega Viid siis kirjutada? Ee, tavaliselt. Noh Selles. Mõttes, et mina nagu puutusin põhimõtteliselt kolme nelja analüütikuga kokku ja minu Kogemus oli see absoluutselt, et mida kogenum Ee, analüütik oli,
Õpetaja: seda vähem teksti sa temalt said nii öelda, Sellepärast,
Õpetaja: Ee, see see natuke tuleb ka sellest. Võibolla, et et kui sul on nagu mingi tuumikmeeskond, on nagu olnud aastaid koos
Õpetaja: ja siis sul on, ee, mingisugune analüütik onju, et kui ta on aastaid teinud tööd, ee. Nende teiste
Õpetaja: arendajatega siis need teised arendajad tunnevad läbi ja lõhki seda projekti ja seda programmi, seda rakendust.
Õpetaja: Ee, noh, neile piisabki tegelikult ka enne nagu, et, noh, annad selle mingi Ül Basic info kätte sellepärast, et sa tead et nad niikuinii kõiki teisi asju teavad. Niikuinii, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, No see laiskus tuleb natukene. Võibolla kuidagi ma pakun. Tuleb seal,
Õpetaja: No ja siis ongi, Kes on, ee, need uued? Sest nad on lihtsalt niivõrd püüdlikud. Nad ka võibolla iseenda jaoks teevad alles seda asja seal kirjalikult niiöelda selgeks Ja, Ja, noh, võibolla on ka ei ole veel tekkinud, siis seda võibolla väsimust, et sa kirjutad tuhanded
Õpetaja: tuhandendat tiketid, on ju,
Õpetaja: ja Noh, siis hakkama tuleb saada. Loomulikult mõlema, aga. Aga noh, vaata ka, et ega selles mõttes, kui sa kirjutad mulle nagu kolm rida teksti, vaata Siis ma olen sul mingi uus uus parim sõber, kes iga päev käib sind tüütamas. Sellepärast, et nagu informatsiooni pole lihtsalt,
Õpetaja: ee, et et See nagu see on, siis. Noh, lõppkokkuvõttes kuskilt, siis see aeg peab tulema ikkagi. Noh, see informatsioon peab jõudma, Vaata, onju?
Õpetaja: Noh, minu küsimus Nendest seostest, onju? Kui ma vaatan neid, taaske, onju? Mis ilmselgelt? Ee,
Õpetaja: on seal väike lahk heli, et järelikult peab see plaan olema. Sinu peas, Mida me siin teeme Järgi
Õpetaja: See plaan peab olema peas. Jah, ja. Ja.
Õpetaja: Ja. Ja kui tuleme nende püüdlike asjade juurde ka, et, Ee, isegi kus on tegelikult taas ka hästi pikalt lahti kirjutatud. Siis see endiselt veel ei tähenda tegelikult seda, et, ee,
Õpetaja: et ee, et Seal taaskis on kogu informatsioon olemas, et see on tegelikult väga normaalne. Ee asi, et ee arendaja tegelikult jõuab arenduses kuskile väga spetsiifilisse kohta
Õpetaja: Ja Siis ta, nagu järsku saab aru. Vaata, et et tegelikult siin taas seda nüüd ei ütle. Ühtepidi ega teistpidi
Õpetaja: ja see ongi väga normaalne. Vaata, et. Ee, siis, ee. Ka Niiöelda analüütik, nagu ei suuda. Nagu, kõike nagu hoomata ja hallata arendajal, on See selles mõttes lihtne, Vaata, ta lihtsalt. Noh, ta teeb seda asja ja ta jõuab kuhugi kohta, et ta on põhimõtteliselt juures. Vaata, ta teab selles kohas, et
Õpetaja: et tegelikult siin. On nagu mingid hästi spetsiifilised nüansid, millega nagu tuleb arvestada. Ja, noh, see on nagu normaalne, et siis sa lähedki lihtsalt Analüütiku juurde. Ja Küsid. Vahel Isegi analüütik ei tea Seda Vastust ütleb. Kuule, tead, ma pean sinna äripoolega midagi arutama, et, noh,
Õpetaja: me nagu ei ole üldse sellest nagu rääkinud, et Vaata, et me pole sellele asjale mõelnudki. Vaata ja siis sa hakkad seal ootama, onju? Ja sellepärast ongi tavaliselt arendajatel mitu taaskeda nagu kaina. Nagu tegevuses, et vahepeal nagu sa ei saa nagu mingit asja teha sellepärast, et lihtsalt ei ole Nagu teada, kuidas me liigume.
Õpetaja: Noh, vahel on isegi niimoodi olnud, et täitsa tuleb mingi miiting korraldada ja veits arutada. Vaata, et asi on Nagu Palju palju. Nagu suurem kui esmapilgul tundus.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga jah, nagu. Mis puudutab siis sellesse, et, noh, su siuke arendaja või arendajal, ei Ole nagu seda tegelikult vabadust, et ta võib ise otsustada, et kuidas. Nagu mingisugust asja. Nagu äripoole mõttes. Nagu nagu teha. Aga mis see nagu juhtuma hakkab. Vaata, onju,
Õpetaja: See on ka jälle Kõik sõltub. Kujutame, ette, et kui meil on mingisugune kahe mehe, ee, kolme mehe Startup Vaata, onju? Siis me oleme ise need tooteomanikud, analüütikud ja nii edasi, et seal lihtsalt siis aja niiöelda nappuse huvides või ressursside huvides, sa Lihtsalt kiirelt. Liigud edasi ja
Õpetaja: võtad mingi otsuse vastu. Võibolla Ütled teistele ka, et Noh, teeme nüüd niimoodi või või ma tegin niimoodi, või Mis iganes, onju?
Õpetaja: Kui räägime ikka klassikalist tööd, siis ee. Ikkagi need asjad mis taaskist nagu välja ei tule. Ee, et ee aga vaja on nagu ühte või teist suunda, siis sa tegelikult ikkagi pead selle kuidagi kommunikeerima, ja nagu läbi arutama, et kuidas seda loomingulisust ei ole, Infosüsteemides, onju?
Õpetaja: Sa avastad nagu mingi mingis kohas. Vaata, et ma ei tea, mingid andmed on puudu või, või sa lihtsalt sa saadki lihtsalt loogikaga aru. Vaata, eriti kui mingi teise süsteemi vastu integreerimine. Ee, et et siin saab nagu mingeid erinevaid pidi nagu minna või või ei ole kindel või isegi isegi tajud. Vaata, et siin on mingisugune seik. Vaata, kus isegi väga valikut pole
Õpetaja: Ee, mingisugune nüanss niiöelda selgineb nii öelda, et mingid valikud niikuinii pole. Suund on õige, aga taaskis ei ole lihtsalt seda kuidagi kirjas. Siis on ka see, et by the way Niukene Konks noh. Niimoodi, peab niikuinii tegema vaata. Ega, sa mingit muud lahendust pole aga? Nüüd me peame olema teatud vaata onju,
Õpetaja: ee et niuksed asjad, nagu on
Õpetaja: minu projekt minu analüütik. Keegi ei saanud mulle üldse infot anda.
Õpetaja: Ja ma olin nagu see peamine inimene, kes Ütlesid testsijatega Ja
Õpetaja: et see minu jaoks oli ka päris nagu siuke.
Õpetaja: Okei, mul on lihtsalt arvele, aga ma nii palju suhtlen, nagu
Õpetaja: ee, Isegi mitte meie osapoolega, vaid nagu hoopis teise firmaga ja minu. Nagu ülemused. Nii palju. Isegi
Õpetaja: selline sarnane asi võib juhtuda ka siis, kui Näiteks tööle kuskile. Niiöelda rätsepaarendusettevõttesse, on ju? Kus niiöelda tehakse arendusi teistele? Seal on ka lõpuks niimoodi. Et. Jah, okei, alguses on sul võibolla Mingi kontakt või mis iganes, kes. Nagu oma meeskonnas mingi.
Õpetaja: Hakkame tegema sellele ettevõttele mingisugust asja ja nii edasi. Aa, aga mingi hetk siis, Kui see asja nagu tegemiseks läheb, siis on niimoodi, et sa peadki tegelikult otse suhtlema kliendiga,
Õpetaja: sest et sul on küsimused, nagu mida ainult Tema oskab vastata ja pole mõtet mängida mingit telefoni ka. Ee, isegi kui mingi projektijuht on seal ka võibolla in The Loop. Vaata, kui Need on mingid tehnilised küsimused. Vaata, onju
Õpetaja: arusaamine, et kuidas. Mis moodi? Ja on ka üldse seda ka, et kus tegelikult see on lausa Ootus. Ee, et ee.
Õpetaja: Kui nüüd juba mingi aeg ettevõttes ikkagi olnud on, siis ongi see ka setup. Et Tegelikult, meil ei olegi nagu Otseselt analüütikute puhul ei olegi hästi. Ongi null. Vaata, ongi otse Suhtlus Alguses. Võibolla suhtled nagu kogenuma arendaja kliendiga. Aga See aja jooksul on Tegelikult osa tööst. Vaata, kliendiga suhtlemine.
Õpetaja: Ee, mida täpselt on Vaja On ju, et
Õpetaja: sa kõige, mida vähem on tegelikult selles Ee, jadas nagu inimesi vahel seda parem Tegelikult on, et Vaata, see on see kiige värk jälle. Vaata, et mida see klient tahab on ju?
Õpetaja: Mida rohkem On inimesi siin niiöelda selles niiöelda siin pulkadena vahel. Seda suurem tõenäosus on see, et inimesed mõistavad tegelikult seda probleemi või lahendust, mis iganes Erinevat on ju? Ja info hakkab vaikselt nagu. Nagu kaduma minema.
Õpetaja: Ma kogesin ka seda oma ettevõttes Kuigi, Noh, olin nagu kliendi või tähendab kliendi vastu.
Õpetaja: Tootlus,
Õpetaja: kus see trendihaldus nendel vahel oli,
Õpetaja: ei saanud. Jah, ja mul on ka olnud sellist kogemust, kus kuidagi üritatakse ülistrikt vaata hoida kedagi, et keegi on vahendaja, siis tegelikult vahel on isegi tekitanud frustratsiooni et ma ei tohi otsene kliendiga suhelda. Mul on niuksed, noh, Mitte arenduses. Mujal on nagu, olnud, et
Õpetaja: on tegelikult nagu väga närvidele käinud, nagu see. Vaata, ma saan aru, et esiteks on see pidev Ootamine. Vaata, see tekib, kui on mingi inimene vahel. Vaata, noh, mina ütlen sulle selle.
Õpetaja: Jah, jah, ma olen ka seda teinud.
Õpetaja: Ma olen Niuke Rebeli et terve elu olen ma kohe läinud. Ja, noh, vahel on saanud kõrvetada ka. Vaata, et vahel vahel olen saanud kiita pigem Onju, et kõik, kuidas nagu asjad välja tuleb. Et
Õpetaja: Ma nagu ise mõtlen, et ma. Tahan aru saada. Lahti. Vaatan, kas see meetodite blokk, Mis kuivõrd? Noh, see ongi mingi kokkulepete küsimus. Aga mul on see meetodite järjekord.
Õpetaja: Võibolla polegi nii oluline, et ma. Nagu internetiidist ilmselt tulen Idest ja klikk on sinna. Vaatame, mis käivad.
Õpetaja: No jah, see nüüd ongi. Täpselt see. See on see sama asi, mille juurde me jõuame Nagu tagasi. Vaata, et, ee, et et selles mõttes selle tööriistad teevad selle asja nagu lihtsa lihtsamaks. Vaata et ma saan klikida ühte kohta Ja Teise kohta on ju.
Õpetaja: Aga selle selle mõte. Muidugi on see ka, et. Okei, sa saad klikkida, aga ekraanid on nagu selles mõttes Piisavalt suured, et. No ma toon näite. Näiteks selle. Aa, sama Get Cities, onju, et. Ee, for sure. See esimene meetod, mis siin välja kutsutakse. Mis on siin samas failis? On? See meetod. On ju
Õpetaja: sest, et see meetodus asub kuskil mujal. Sellest ei ole üldse juttu Praegu Ta paneks, paika
Õpetaja: et. Ee. Noh, jaavas on see veel isegi kuidagi veel kuidagi märksa nagu, ee, niiöelda teema. Aga
Õpetaja: kui see meetod asub Ikkagi kohe siin Samas all on mul võimalus niimoodi, et ma ei pea klikkima ja kuhugi minema, et, noh, vahel ikkagi on nagu. Võtame Võibolla korra selle transaction types I. Need on kõik lihtsad meetodid. Võibolla pigem läheks loo kinni alla. Korra.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin meil oli võibolla ee, Natukene rohkem, Okei, printsiibis. Ma saan siin selle ka nagu ära näidata, Onju, et
Õpetaja: kuna see meetod asub otse siin all, siis mul on Võimalik lihtsalt silmadega seda vaadata, et ma ei pea klikkima. Kui ma tõstan, tõstan selle ära. Vaata, onju? Lähen kuskile siia all the Way alla
Õpetaja: Panin siin mingi viimase koha, kus selle toppida.
Õpetaja: Noh, ilma klikkides Loomulikult saan tulla siia,
Õpetaja: et ma olen siin spons alla ma vaadata ei saa siin. Seda meetodit. Pole. Ainukene variant mul nüüd ongi. Vaata, ma klikin siia.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma tahaks nagu jätkata. Vaata, on ju siis Ma elan nagu tagasi, et mis siin veel toimub? Et, ee, see on nagu selles mõttes lõppkokkuvõttes saad selle igal juhul ära vaadata. Aga Ee, siin ikkagi väikene. Niiöelda, Delay on korraks pilt. Hüüp Lep.
Õpetaja: Kui see oleks kohe lihtsalt siin all, on ju, et ma nagu näen, Isegi kui ma klikin sellele, ta juba läheb siin põlema. Või isegi kui ma klikin siia. Ta liigub palju vähem nagu,
Õpetaja: ee, et see See selles mõttes. Ma ütlesin, et tehniliselt see ei oma absoluutselt mitte mingit tähtsust vahet, pole kus nad meetodid asuvad, et vahet pole, mis järjekorras Nad asuvad, ega see. Noh, arvuti on ikka arvuti. Tema nagu läheb lihtsalt rida Realt Ühest meetodist läheb teise tuleb tagasi ja nii edasi, et tema jaoks ei ole nagu seal vahet.
Õpetaja: Aga. Aga nagu ka koodilugeja jaoks ikkagi mingisugune vahe, on
Õpetaja: et selles mõttes ikkagi tegelikult Poliitika meetodid ikka võimalikult lähestikku Nagu üksteisele, kus nagu need asjad tulid.
Õpetaja: Ee, seda võib kutsuda ka väljakutsumise hierarhia. Vaata, kui me hakkamegi selle Gat Citysega pihta. No see on nagu üli. Vaata on ju, et kas peab olema tingimata Niukene süsteem et näiteks, et kõigepealt on need meetodid. Niiöelda, mis Before käivitab ja siis tuleb klikitab Või Vastupidi,
Õpetaja: see on Niukene. Juba Ekstreemseks läheb Asi Vaata, onju, et hoiame mingit mustrid
Õpetaja: Aga sellega on ka niimoodi nagu. Noh, see ongi. See sellega on. Muidugi on ka niimoodi. Minu arvamus on selles, et kui mina nagu Ikkagi teeksin projekti. Siis ma üritaksin igal pool olla võimalikult nagu korrektne ja metoodiline ja süsteemiline, Nagu et igal pool on nagu lihtsam, koodi lugeda. Igal pool on lihtsam koodi juurde kirjutada, leida neid kohti ja nii edasi, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ja. Ja võibolla hakkab ka natuke nagu väikestest asjadest. Vaata, et et ee,
Õpetaja: kui tulevad sisse nagu need kohad. Vaata, et Aa, ma ei viitsi või või ma ei hakka selle peale aega kulutama et need väiksed asjad. Vaata, kus sa nagu hakkad tegema. Järeleandmisi, võivad aja jooksul lihtsalt kuidagi kasvada, nagu et kõigil on lõpuks ülisavi. Vaata, et kõik on nagu
Õpetaja: pudru ja kapsast, et. Noh, kui ikka vaatad. Nagu mingi High Level kirjutatud koodi, ma ei tea kirjutatud koodi. Näiteks Eesti energiast nägid Sa kohe, said aru? Vaatad siuke üld, nagu. Süsteemne. Kõik on nagu täpi pealt sama muster nagu käekiri on Nagu täiesti perfektne, onju?
Õpetaja: Ei, no tegelikult. Lhv S ka ikkagi, kui me kirjutasime. Seal,
Õpetaja: Noh, kui me räägime, mingi maksete rakendusest, mis oli see põhiline nii öelda Rakendusjaavas. Ee, mis seal niiöelda toimetab, siis seal ka ikkagi. Tegelikult oli pigem oli Niukene nagu väga korrektne struktuur või üsna Nagu korrektne. Isegi oleks võinud muidugi alati olla selline parem. Ma isegi vahel mõtlen nagu
Õpetaja: ee.
Õpetaja: Kolmkümmend, palun.
Õpetaja: Ja Ja kirja kirja. Kindlasti Jah, jah, töötab.
Õpetaja: Töötab suht hästi. Ee, aga isegi siis. No kui me pakendi läheme, siis võibolla hakkame vaatama Juba Järgmine nädal on ju Kindlasti,
Õpetaja: ee, et kui me hakkame seal nagu toimetama ja õpetan neid nippe, Loomulikult, Ee, Point ongi nagu see, et sa tahaksidki et see Ai kirjutaks nagu ütleme, ülejäänud meeskond. Vaata. Ja sa tahaksid, et kõik kirjutaksid täpselt sama niiöelda stiili. Ta
Õpetaja: suures pildis saab suhteliselt hästi, Ee, hakkama. Aga. Aga mitte nagu alati, et ta nagu ikkagi teeb. Ka nagu vigu. No ma toon näite näiteks, et
Õpetaja: kui mina tegin ee seda klassirahade Niiöelda projekti tegin, et. Ee, siis, ee. Ta kip. Ma tahtsin niimoodi, et kui me vaatasime kontroller klassi, kus on siis definitsioonid, et üks või teine sõnum, mis saab sisse tulla.
Õpetaja: Ja nagu pihta Nii öelda. Et ma tahtsin, et alati oleks nagu järjekorras. Kõigepealt tuleb postmeetod,
Õpetaja: siis tulevad read. Meetodid nagu kett Meetodid on ju? Ma tahtsin alati, niimoodi et alati, on niimoodi, et kõigepealt üksik objekt, kui on mingi meetod. Kui on mingi list, siis tulevad listed. Siis tuleb Update ja divid. Ma tahtsin lihtsalt et oleks nagu mingi kindel süsteem
Õpetaja: ja mul selles siin. Ee, aile käivad niuksed abistavad juhendid kaasas, millega ta arvestab. Ja mul on juhendus peaaegu lõpuks juba mingi
Õpetaja: kaks korda nagu toonitatud, et hoia seda nagu sellest järjekorrast kinni. Iga kord, kui sa lisad uue meetodi, vaata, siis otsi see õige koht. Vaatad, kuhu sa panna, et palun järgi täpselt sellist järjekorda Mul ikka, nagu läks aega. Ee, kuidas ma kogu aeg mitu korda pidin neid juhiseid Timmima,
Õpetaja: Ee, Et ee, et Et tal nagu hakkas töötama, et hakkas seda respektima,
Õpetaja: et päris palju enamus asju respektib. Väga hästi. Vaata, sa ütled meetodit Niimoodi aga siis ongi niimoodi. Ikkagi siin. Seal lipsab pidevalt ikkagi midagi sisse ka Vaata,
Õpetaja: ee, ta nagu ignoorib. See võib juhtuda ka seda. Vaata, kui need juhised, mis nagu tal on. Vaata, niiöelda muutuvad väga pikaks.
Õpetaja: Ma olen aru saanud, et siis hakkavad asjad nagu et senikaua Kuni need juhised. Ee, nagu juhised, mis on nagu alalised. Juhised ongi. Niukene fail Fail. Nagu
Õpetaja: on projekti juures. Seda ta loeb iga kord sisse kui Projekti Ava
Õpetaja: Ee ja ja siis pärast hiljem. Ee, failid. Näiteks konkreetsed reeglid Backendi kohta. Konkreetsed reeglid Frontend I kohta, et ee Kui nad hakkavad minema pikaks Ja kuidas nad lähevad pikaks?
Õpetaja: Minu kogemus on nagu selline olnud, et kui ma töötan niiöelda ja kirjutan mingeid projekte ja teen mingit asja iga kord. Kui ta teeb mingi koodilõigu siis ma vaatan üle. Kui mul midagi ei meeldi, siis ma ütlen talle, et. Kuule, Lisa, palun sinna. Juhista alla, et
Õpetaja: ära nii tee
Õpetaja: tee Nii aga, noh, niimoodi hakkabki see asi nagu kasvama. Vaata, on ju, et sa saaksid teda vormida nagu aja jooksul. Ee, sellisesse stiili nagu sinule nagu meeldib,
Õpetaja: et ee. Aga ma arvan, et see on ka niimoodi, et need mudelid lähevad paremaks. Järjest Rohkem hakkab sellest kinni hoidma. Aa, järjest rohkem tuleb aja jooksul. Aa kogemust, Vaata, et mismoodi kirjutada. Vaata neid juhiseid, et ta saaks paremini aru. Ja ma selles mõttes tunnen nagu kadedust. Vaata, ma hea meelega tahaks töötada praegu kuskil
Õpetaja: Aa, ettevõttes. Ee, kas poole kohaga? Aa, kus käib mingi High level Mingi high arendus niiöelda. Ja ma tahaks näha, tahaks näha. Vaata kuidas neile on. Kujuta ette, on osa projektist see fail.
Õpetaja: Ee, et kujuta ette, kui sul on nagu mingi profit, kes igapäevaselt töötavad ja nende Nende Ai Ga onju. Ja aja jooksul ju nad ju kogu aeg täiendavad. Täiendavad, täiendavad, täiendavad ja täiendavad neid juhiseid,
Õpetaja: et ee need kindlasti Tegelikult on lõpuks päris päris head.
Õpetaja: Millega lõpuks juba võibki. Nagu öelda, et tee mulle see asi ja ta teeb selle asja ära,
Õpetaja: No See ongi see mõte. Vaata, kui sa käisid, siis niuksel Miitingu, kus arutati seda, et mis sa nagu juuniorite nagu tulevik on ja mis, Nagu ootused. Neil on. Kus paneel oli selles mõttes seisukohal, et täna ikka, ee, peab olema. Nagu täna peab olema see, et koodi peab tundma ja teadma.
Õpetaja: Aa, ja seal ruumis oli inimesi, kes keegi oli nagu mingi, väga, väga nagu Niukene tugev. Vaata, et tegelikult põhimõtteliselt polegi üldse vaja arendada, et
Õpetaja: et kui sul on nagu absoluutselt skill Id nagu need samad, asjad, kui sul on kõik nagu üli, nagu pilvasteks võetud, et kui sa teed tee seda asja. Jälgi seda. Tood bla, bla, bla. Et kui sul on kõik kõik nagu sellised asjad olemas, Et sa saad nagu agendina. Pane käima, et tee mulle tee. Mul pank, Teeb interneti. Pank nagu onju, et saab sellega hakkama,
Õpetaja: Ee, ja. Ja et ta põhimõtteliselt nagu arendajat polegi vaja. Aga ma ütlengi täna Tegelikult, Ee, on selge see, et see asi veel päris neil ei toimi, aga läheme kaugemale.
Õpetaja: Jah, miks mitte, onju
Õpetaja: Ma arvan ka, et nüüd see arendaja arendaja roll tegelikult aja ajas hakkab muutuma rohkem niukseks, Ee analüütiliseks. Ee, väga heaks. Nagu,
Õpetaja: väga, väga heaks. Lihtsalt nagu Heaks Vaata vaid väga heaks. Nagu struktureeritud lähenemisega. Kaine nagu projekti juht nagu Slash,
Õpetaja: tooteomanik ja analüüdi. Kõik kuidagi ühes kompotis. Aga selle vahega Vaata, onju, et ee, et ta ikkagi mõistab. Vaata, kuidas seal taustal need Suures pildis. Need asjad omavahel töötavad süsteemis. Nagu Vaata, kuidas. Süsteemis suhtled nii edasi. Aga koodi võib olla tingimata ei peagi enam jääma sinna jõuame. Igal juhul.
Õpetaja: Sa tegid seda nii öelda. Kirjutasid seifesi Masin loetavalt.
Õpetaja: Ei, no ma rohkem üldse toimetan. Md nagu failidega. Vaata, et minu Minu struktuur oli selles mõttes ikkagi informatsioon, mis annaks nagu Jason ka samamoodi. Kõik veebiteenused, palun Väga Seesama asi, mida Sväger näitab, see on osa Projektist
Õpetaja: Point on selles, et kui sa annad selle samas stiilis, nagu oli treeningdatos et põhimõtteliselt adnoteeritud et ee,
Õpetaja: siis ta saab sellest palju paremini aru ja juhib üldse.
Õpetaja: Jah, aga ma ka seda kasutasin ka. Ma ütlen, ongi täpselt see Sama Jason. Näiteks mida
Õpetaja: see sama Jason, näiteks mis? Ee,
Õpetaja: kui mina tegin. Ee, tegin seda projekti Hakkasin tegema Siis ma disainisin kohe ära. Vaata, kõik need
Õpetaja: kõik need teenused, mida ma kujutasin ette mida nagu läheb. Vaja. Vaata, on ju sellisel kujul nagu see on
Õpetaja: siin olemas ja see oli. See oli osa Niiöelda sellest projektist. See oli osa sellest vestlusest. Igal pool Visuaali pool oli mokk olemas,
Õpetaja: kus olid kõik Aa nootidena kõik teenused sisse teinud, välja, et. Ee, loomulikult. Ee, Ütleme niimoodi, et ma ei näegi. Nagu seda. Ma just mõtlengi selle üle. Ma näen, et tulevikus ongi see, See teadlikkus vaata, et kuidas nii öelda.
Õpetaja: Selle Ai ga nii öelda. Teha koostööd. Niiöelda, et me planeerime nagu mingisugust süsteemi ja planeerime neid teenuseid. Me mõtleme välja. Vaata, kuidas mingisugused asjad toimivad. Ja siis me hakkame seda realiseerima ja siis on niimoodi, et kui sa tahad midagi seal juurde teha.
Õpetaja: Vaata, põhiline on see. Vaata, kui sa tahad midagi juurde teha. Kui sul ei ole mitte mingisugust nagu sellist, niiöelda masin loetavat dokumentatsiooni ja informatsiooni siis on väga keeruline Ee, teha asju juurde niimoodi, et ainult koodibaasi pealt, nagu kõike peaks nagu endaga nagu haarama aru saama.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui Kodex kirjutab koodist. Ee, salvestab endale Mb Sse, mida ta tegi. Ja kui projekt jääb seisma ja pärast midagi, teha, Siis ta iga kord kuuek selle läbi pidama.
Õpetaja: Ja,
Õpetaja: noh, seda küll. Vaata, see aitab ka kindlasti. Ja on kindlasti. Võta vaata, mida kasutada, Vaata, et tal on nagu mälu varasemast asjast,
Õpetaja: Aga noh, millal? Nagu jaanik, nagu viitab, on ikkagi struktureeritud informatsioon, mis millest nagu masin saab väga lihtsalt aru, et kui sul on nagu ütlengi, et see saabki olema kompott kõigest. Vaata, on ju, et, ee,
Õpetaja: ee, Noh, seda õpime siin ka selle kursuse jooksul. Kui te hakkate projekte tegema, et mina annan suunad kätte. Kuidas mina näitan, et kuidas, võiks nagu proovida
Õpetaja: läheneda uue süsteemi nii öelda disainimisel ja loomisel. Ja siis selle realiseerimisel.
Õpetaja: Noh, see on muidugi väga selles piiratud nagu ajamahus, vaata. Onju, et meil Ei ole nagu nii palju aega. Ee, seda siin niimoodi vaadata Ja nagu õppida.
Õpetaja: Aga. Aga et jah, tulevik nagu ma arvangi, et noh, Me veel vaatame koodi ka. Ega me nagu niimoodi ei tee? Vaatame koode. Ei, vaata, on ju
Õpetaja: koodi. Peab vaatama, nagu tee eesmärk. Meil Selles mõttes projektidel saab olema hästi lihtne. Aga meil saab olema üks asi, mis me kokku lepime. Ma annan teile selles mõttes vabad käed, Te võite minu pärast teha kogu projekti ka. Ära. Ee, ai abiga. Vaata otsast lõpuni. Niimoodi ridagi Koodi ei kirjuta.
Õpetaja: Aga selle eelduseks saab olema see. Vaata, et iga selle koodireast vastutad ikkagi ise.
Õpetaja: Ja mis Ühel hetkel, kui mina küsin, mis mi, mida see osa siin täpsemalt teeb, siis seal ei ole aktsepteeritav vastust. See, et ma ei tea, et Aa ei tegi. Vaata,
Õpetaja: et ee, et isegi kui Ai teeb teile mingi elegantse lahenduse, siis tegelikult te peate seda dudeerima ja aru saama, kuidas see toimib, mida see teeb ja selgitama nagu ära, vaata, et kuidas see nagu toimib ja mis seal, nagu taustal toimub.
Õpetaja: Ja Ja, noh, mingit one shot imist. Ma kindlasti ei tee nagu, et Ee, väga lihtne on kirjutada kokku. Tegelikult hästi põhjalik ja hea dokumentatsioon. Mida te niikuinii teete, on kogu see staff ette vaata sellele, tee mulle see asi valmis.
Õpetaja: Noh, ronistab seal mingi järgmised mingi kolmkümmend minutit ja teedki ära. Vaata, on ju Aga nad ei tulnud sedasi õppima,
Õpetaja: Te võite seda pärast oma projektidest teha. Ma ütlen ka, et mina hakkasin nagu tegema ikkagi infosüsteemi. Isegi Ai abiga. Mulle ei tulnud isegi mõttesse see. Vaata, et ma teeksin nagu selle mingi one shot iga ära. Põhimõtteliselt, et, noh, et ma teen kogu dokumentatsiooni valmis ja ütlen, et tee lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: No sellepärast, et kui mul on ikkagi mõte, et mul on nagu infosüsteem, mis nagu peab jätkusuutlikult nüüd edaspidi toimetama, siis Ma tahan seda tüki kaupa ehitada
Õpetaja: ja kui ta suudab tüki kaupa seda korrektselt ehitada, siis ma tean, et ma suudan tüki kaupa korrektselt ka selle pärast täiendada. Vaata, onju.
Õpetaja: Noh, ajanappuses võiks ka seda teha. Tegelikult ma mõtlen, nagu, kui nagu plaan on mingi asjaga ruttu kuidagi valmis olnud. Ma ei ütle et see kuidagi halb on, aga ma kindlasti nagu seda
Õpetaja: ise, kui ma tahaksin seda, kui ma vähegi tahaksin seda. Kas et kasutajad tõesti saavad sellest abi. Ja see on mingi pikaajaline asi, mis nüüd jääbki elama ja toimetab. Vaata, olgu see tasuline Või tasuta Vahet pole, siis ma täna kindlasti seda, nagu ei teeks niimoodi, Et ta, Nagu ütlen, et tee mulle kogu asi valmis ega Mitte midagi ei mõista sellest,
Õpetaja: sest ma tahan ka teha seda. Vaata ka, et kui ta hakkab seda asja tegema, täpselt samale asjale, mina Veel Ikkagi. Tahan koodi lugeda. Õppida ka sellest. Ma näiteks, kui ma tegin seda projekti, mitte ühte ainsat rida, ei läinud sinna koodist Ma Tahtsin ka teha. Varem polnud kokku puutunud.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tahtnud niimoodi et ma loen koodi ja ma ei saa sellest ööde ega mütsi aru, Millega siin on tegemist?
Õpetaja: Iga kord, kui ta tegi mingisuguse väikse lõigu Mingi uue koodi või asja Mingi lõigu, kus sees oli minu jaoks Täiesti mingi tundmatud võtted ja süntaks mulle nagu kohe Nagu Palun, Skill tee sellest õppematerjal. Palun selgita, mis. Kuidas asi see on,
Õpetaja: mismoodi see töötleb, onju? Mida ma kõike pean teadma, on ju? Ma ei liikunud enne mitte kuhugi edasi. Vaata, kui kui ma sain selle selgeks, siis Ma veel mõtlesin, kas mina täpselt niimoodi tahan teha. Kas ma tahaks, et ta muster oleks mingi teistsugune? Et ma mõtlen nagu, seda, vaata, et
Õpetaja: seal oligi ka see asi juures et, ee, ma tahan ka kontrollida seda. Vaata, et tuleb selline niiöelda käekirja Muster, vaata, mis minule Nagu tundub nagu loogiline ja loetav. Ja minule arusaadav.
Õpetaja: Kui sa lased kogu selle asja valmis teha, siis sa vaatad, et see käekiri ei Vasta absoluutselt sellisele mudelile, nagu sina tahaks, siis oleks nagu see, et kui sa nüüd hakkad mingit asja ringi tegema, mis Sa oled nagu Seal lähevad asjad niikuinii. Varem või hiljem Tuksi ülisuur tõenäosus igast pugidele asjadele. Onju,
Õpetaja: et ee, ehitad ikkagi asja nagu tegelikult jupi kaupa Kontrollid Kas see töötab? Mul on nagu parem lahendus. Vähemalt vähemalt selline, asi, mis peaks nagu jääma ajas kestma. Ja kui tahad midagi õppida, ka
Õpetaja: Suurepärane võimalus, et niimoodi On väga, raske, et kui tee mul infosüsteem valmis ja sa võid mõelda, et. Oh, küll ma siis hakkan teda Nagu küsitlema Ja et kuidas see toimib ja nii edasi. Tead, sa lähed ülikiirelt voolavalt üle nendest asjadest. Aa, jah, korra. Vaatad loed, See on järjekordselt loed mingit materjali. Vaatad mingit materjali? Ma nüüd õppisin mingi asja. Noh, palun väga. Kas sa oled võimelised ise kirjutama?
Õpetaja: Noh, kas Kui ligilähedaselt Okei, Päris syntax it ei tea, Vaata, onju? Aa, ei, nagu siis ei ole Kasu vaata onju,
Õpetaja: aga jah, ütleme nii et Kui ma näiteks seda klassiraha projekti. Mingi hetk, et kui ma seda nagu tegin, siis ma tegelikult väga, väga tahtsin hästi palju õppida, ka ma nüüd hiljem olen ka teinud mingisuguseid asju ja ma lihtsalt nagu ajanaputuses ei olegi tegelikult enam väga koodi vaadanud,
Õpetaja: et lihtsalt see ei ole nagu olnud minu jaoks Primaarne primaarne on olnud nagu mingi asi. Nagu tööle saada.
Õpetaja: Ee, küll muidugi. Ka. Näiteks üks Ai projekt, mis Ma tegin.
Õpetaja: Ee. Seal ma ikkagi Selles mõttes üritasin koolist aru saada, aga ma saingi aru, et kuradi ma raske on aru saada, kui Sa oled tegelikult väga niuksed Tähtsad, ja päris suured ja mahukad asjad. Oled Aile andnud, niiöelda üle niiöelda vaatamiseks ja tegemiseks
Õpetaja: ja siis, sa Saadki aru, et tema ongi teinud selle tehniliselt täiesti toimiva korrektse niiöelda asja. Aga koodi loetavus on niimoodi, et mine ja pekki nagu ausõna,
Õpetaja: Sa Ei, saa mitte midagi aru, nagu sul on nagu nii keeruline aru saada. Sellepärast, et sa ei ole teinud seda ise. Jupiti, vaata,
Õpetaja: ma aru saaks.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: siis ongi see siis tema. Siis on lihtsalt see. Vaata, et temal sinul on erinev arusaam. Vaata, mida tähendab, nagu Tee see arusaadavaks. Vaata
Õpetaja: sinuga harjunud.
Õpetaja: Jah, kõik on võimalik. Kõiki on võimalik teha. Minu Nagu pigem sõnum on nagu see. Vaata, et me Ei, peagi nagu Agriima. Vaata, onju, Minu arvamus on see. Vaata, et tegelikult ikkagi. Kui aega on, siis Tegelikult tuleks neid asju niimoodi jupiti
Õpetaja: teha Isegi need. Ee, keerulised funktsionaalsused ja asjad. Vaata, mis on, tuleb tõmmata. Juppideks
Õpetaja: Tuleb teha niimoodi vaikselt ja. Ja ee selles etapis Vaata, Kui Ta juba. Teeb mingit väikest osa, Vaata, onju? Ja sa vaatad, et minu jaoks see kood on nagu loetamatu Noh, siis ma võitleksingi temaga. Tee see mulle arusaadavaks või lepime kokku või saame aru. On ju, et
Õpetaja: mida? Rohkem nagu sa annad, Nagu ära selle kontrolli, et Tema teeb mingi komplekse asja nagu,
Õpetaja: ee, täiesti otsast lõpuni. Nagu ise valmis.
Õpetaja: Ee, jah, loomulikult. Ma ütlen ka, et sa võid temaga pärast Tee paremaks ühtepidi ja teistpidi Tee arusaadavamaks. Aga lihtsalt see esialgne punkt on juba niivõrd nagu nagu teistsuguse ee, stiiliga lahendusega keerukusega, et sul on raske seda ikkagi hoomata,
Õpetaja: et sa saad aru. Vaata, küll onju. Aga lihtsalt ongi see, et. Kas ütleme niimoodi, kui mina, nagu lahenduse Koodi oleks andnud mingisuguse teise inimese käte, mis ta nagu lõpuks valmis tegi, Siis mina arvan, et noh, seal oleks peaaegu peab võimatu nagu aru saada Vaata, mis seal toimub.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et see see lihtsalt. No see oli hästi keeruline probleem. Ka keeruline lahendus ja nii edasi, et See oli niiöelda. See oli promp, mida ma lihvisin. Ja mitte prompt, vaid dokumentatsioon. Taaske taaskeimplementatsiooni fail. Mida ma lihvisin. Ma ei tea, kui Kui kaua Terve päeva? Peaaegu igatepidi? Nagu grillisin üle käisin.
Õpetaja: Tüübil ei saanudki nagu küsimused. Otsa. Vaata, et kuidas see, nagu, täpselt nagu peab, toimima ja nii edasi. See oli tohutu asi. Ma lõpuks andsin selle asja nagu ragistada. Vaata, see oligi nii keeruline, aga ma vähemalt teadsin seda protsessi asja, et mul oli teoreetiline võimalus seda koodi lugeda. Mis oli ikkagi tundus, et paganama raske,
Õpetaja: aga ma ütlen, et kui keegi lihtsalt kõrvalt tuleks, siis peaks lihtsalt koodile otsa vaatama. Siis ma ei tea.
Õpetaja: Its gonna be tough aga lähme edasi. Ärme
Õpetaja: Ee nii kaua Kuni koolitus sajab otsa. Alates sellest hetkest. Kui hakkate tegema
Õpetaja: See sõltub. See See sõltub sellest, kui palju, kuidas me siin edasi liigume, Vaata, Et et mida rohkem me siis seda vähem aega jääb,
Õpetaja: pane mingisugune
Õpetaja: selles mõttes nagunii Siin see kõik pähe ei jää. No seda seda küll, aga lihtsalt pärast on copy Based
Õpetaja: see, eks? Siin kuskil ongi see tasakaal. Vaata, et kui praegult me midagi ei proge ega ei tee. Vaata siis. Me võime äppida, et see teid nagu tegelikult lahendusele lähemale ei vii. On ju,
Õpetaja: et Ee, jah, see on nagu, see On Ka selles mõttes, et. Noh, siin ongi niimoodi, et ega see te saategi tegelikult niukse nagu üli Basic nagu teadmised ja oskused kätte, et te niikuinii hakkate nende asjadega veel siin mässama ja toimetama. Vaata, onju, et
Õpetaja: teie, teie nagu kasuks on see, et vaata, et hakkate kindlasti Aid kasutama. Vaata,
Õpetaja: Ee, aga me me jõuame sinna. See viimane jäppi, mille eest nagu läheme. Päriselt ka teemadega. Et Kohe, tuleb paus ka, onju? Aa,
Õpetaja: üks asi. Noh, ma ütlengi, et reeglid, mis on, on see, mis ma ütlesin, et, ee, te ei tohi hakata, Ma, Ma tunnen kohe ära need. Inimesed, Mul oli eelmine grupp, kus me esimest korda nagu Ai. Tööriistad olid nagu lubatud ja tehtud,
Õpetaja: Mul on Üks, üks, ee.
Õpetaja: Peal. Üks naisterahvas oli. Vaata, kes nagu ei tahtnud ega tahtnud aru saada. Ta one shot is selle kogu fronti ära
Õpetaja: Ja ma ütlesin, nagu, et olete kolmena tiim. Vaata, et põhimõtteliselt võtsid täielikult võimaluse. Ära nüüd teha seda frontarendust. Vaata, et ära tee niimoodi, Vaata, onju?
Õpetaja: Ei, aga ma olen juba nii palju vaeva näinud. Ma mõtlesin,
Õpetaja: mis vaeva sa oled näinud. Sa oled selle kallal mingi, üks, kaks päeva midagi toimetanud ja teinud. Vaata, see ei ole nagu mingi vaev. Sul on su front sisuliselt nagu. Valmis vaata
Õpetaja: ja siis ma hakkasin. Ja siis loomulikult oli puudujääke ka, sellepärast, et see oli täiesti teine süntaks. Täiesti teistsugune lähenemine. Ma võtsin lihtsalt mõtlesin, et Davai teeme Lihtsalt nagu teeme ühe faili lahti ja vaatame korra siia otsa, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ja ma ütlesin, et palun ole hea. Nüüd on ju? Räägi mulle, mida see asi nagu teeb.
Õpetaja: Ei, me ei tea, Siis ma ei tea.
Õpetaja: Ma vaatan sinna otsa. Vaata, et, noh, täiesti teine värk, Vaata, on ju. Ja nagu siis, nagu ma. Üldse, nagu rääkida. Vaata, et ma nagu algusest peale nagu rääkisin. Te ei tulnud siia projekti tegema. Eesmärk ei ole jõuda mingi projektiga valmis
Õpetaja: eesmärki. Eesmärk ei ole absoluutselt kuidagi seotud selle projektiga. Selles mõttes ülikama, kuhu staatusesse see jõuab ülikama. Kui palju demopäeval on näidata või mitte, Te tulite siia õppima. Vaata näiteks see inimene, nagu lihtsalt ei saanud aru, et ta kuni Lõpuni jäi nagu endale kindlaks, et
Õpetaja: jääb see front ja nii kõvasti on tööd tehtud ja. Ja nii edasi,
Õpetaja: Tõesti, Ma ütlesin nagu seda, Et vaata, teil on see dokumentatsioon. Jumala nagu tšillipilli tehtud. Vaata, Hakkaks lihtsalt uuesti tegema, et paneks selle prügikasti. Vaata lihtsalt ja hakkaks nagu Nüüd jupiti seda tegema uuesti vaata, teised poisid selle kõrvale teeks niimoodi. Vaata, onju? See on nagu, ei
Õpetaja: sina suhetes muuseas
Õpetaja: Ja tegelikult oligi seda. Vaata, et lõpus oligi see, et. Ee, täie Ma ütlen ka, see on ka teine. Asi. On nagu kulutame selle viis minutit ära Ja nüüd siis vaatame asju edasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, teine asi, mis ma tegelikult. Mida te tegelikult tulite siia õppima. Ja mis see tegelik väärtus on? On tiimitöö, mitte tiimitöö. Nagu ma mõtlen, projekti mõttes, vaid suhtlemine. Arutamine koos mõtlemine koos pusimine
Õpetaja: koos üksteise tarkuste Niiöelda edendamine,
Õpetaja: tiimitöös ja see Kuidas, nagu inimesed. Mul on nagu suurepäraselt piinlik. Kus sa lihtsalt vaatad inimesed päev läbi hullult panutavad, vaatavad, mõtlevad, kuuled niukseid, lauseid, Vaata, onju, et okei, et. Kas me anname, alla? Et. Kas nüüd spikerdame ja vaatame? Vaata
Õpetaja: mu arutasega. Nad jõudsid sinnamaani, vaata onju kõigepealt ise mõelda ise teha. Ja siis on nagu, see, et. Okei, kas me korra nüüd vaatame? Vaata, et. Noh,
Õpetaja: mingi panga projekti pealt või või vaatame, on ju? Ja üleüldse, nagu arutavad oma süsteemi. Ja nagu kogu aeg, on ninapidi koos
Õpetaja: kogu aeg, sa saad aru? Vaata, et nad teevad erinevaid osasid. Nad koguaeg viivad seda projekti kokku. Nad näitavad üksteisele, mida nad tegid, arutavad. Ma tegin niimoodi, see töötab niimoodi, onju? Ja siis On sul Niukene tiim, kus sa vaatad? Nagu.
Õpetaja: Nagu vaatad. Nagu kahe kolme nädala jooksul Nagu
Õpetaja: toksivad seal Midagi hommikul ütlevad tere. Õhtul ütlevad. Tsau, on ju.
Õpetaja: Nagu siis on nagu see, et. Vau, onju, et nagu tegelikult,
Õpetaja: see ongi tegelikult see midagi erilist. Seda üksinda toksimist te Saate teha mingi suvalise Udemy kursusega ka. Aga seda, et tiimiga koos teha, mõelda arendada üksteist, arendada teineteist, Ee, aidata üksteist ee mõelda. Et
Õpetaja: Ütleme niimoodi, et mul olid tiimid. Kus Olid inimesed, kes nagu tegelikult ei tahtnudki vaid kasutada ja väga ei kasutanudki.
Õpetaja: Ma annan neile ka mingid tööriistad kätte. Vaata, kus Ai hakkab aitama. Ma kutsun seda Rain, Ai onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, kus tegelikult. Põhimõtteliselt ai aitab sind selles osas, et Ta nügib ja suhtleb sinuga. Aga ta ei ütle sulle koodi. Ette. Vaata, väga paljud läksid. Ma ei tahagi tegelikult Ai, ga seda koodi teha. Vaata vaid, ma tahan, et aitaks mul seda.
Õpetaja: Kuidas see progemine käib. Onju
Õpetaja: et ee niiöelda lähenemised olid väga erinevad Suht niiöelda suhtlus oli väga erinev ja minul on loomulikult rõõm näha rohkem niukseid tiime, kes omavahel suhtlevad ja teevad koostööd ja,
Õpetaja: ja, noh, selles mõttes, et Siin on ka see. Vaata, te peate aru saama, et te. Te ei lähe kuskile. Nagu kui te lähete niiöelda progemist tegema üksinda ei tehta. Enam mitte midagi. Meeskondadega tehakse,
Õpetaja: kui Sa oled introvert ja sul on keeruline teiste inimestega suhelda ja tiimis Töötada, palun väga, sul on Siuke turvaline keskkond. Kus sa saad seda siis natukene arendada ja proovida Teha On ju
Õpetaja: et, ee, et, ee, Mõned on nagu ei taha, Nagu õudsalt tahavad üksi nagu nokitseda. See töö lõpuks saabki olema väga palju üksi nokitsemist ka, onju nii selles projektis, kui ka päris töökeskkonnas, Aga päris töö käib ikkagi tegelikult tiimides. Ee, vestlustes, koostöös suheldes ja kõike. Seda, Vaata et.
Õpetaja: Et, ee, kui kui nagu siit seda kaasa endaga ei haara. Vaata, noh, päris production is,
Õpetaja: et, ee, its more about teamwork
Õpetaja: ta on. Ma ei tea, Projekti valmis saamine vaadates, See on kõige viimase
Õpetaja: Teeme selle pausi ära ja tagasi tulles. Ee, siis, ee. Paneme need meetodid igal poole. Järjekorda Ma Näitan idee järgi, et Selle seda ei peagi enam arutlema, et
Õpetaja: tingimata. Mis järjekorras? Kuidas vaid lihtsalt see metoodika? Ee, Kuidas näiteks mina panen meetodid ilusti järjekorda.
Õpetaja: Ma Teen komit I ka ära.
Õpetaja: Panen Ee, rekordi pausile. Panen seda. Mõtled rekordida seda?
Õpetaja: Ee, pausi siia sisse.
Õpetaja: Recording.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: ee, okei, ühesõnaga. Ärme Siis rohkem seda aruta. Vaata, mis järjekorras tingimata need meetodid peaks olema. Aga ma näitan seda meetodit, kuidas mina seda teeks? Ee, before enne Kui Aa, oli selline, asi, et vahepeal intelligen ise kaotab tükki ridvasid ära. Siis ma lihtsalt tegin niimoodi, et ma võtsin nagu mingisuguse alguspunkti,
Õpetaja: Kuhu niiöelda tuli? Niiöelda esimene meetod, mis niiöelda peaks justkui järjekorras olema. Ma meelega valin praegult selle sama meetodi,
Õpetaja: mis siin kõige all on, seda ei pea kaasa tegema. Praegu seda võib lihtsalt vaadata, sest see on lihtsalt süsteem või metodoloogia Kui ma võtaksin praegult siit Ee selle me peamise meetodi, mida saab klikkida Ad location. Ma võtan selle,
Õpetaja: võtan siit Aa Control Iksiga ära ja Ma tõstan ta siia kõige esimeseks. Ma lükkan nüüd ülejäänud asjad alla.
Õpetaja: Aga ma võibolla natukene. Teen seekord teistmoodi, et ma panen siia kommentaari, mis oleks kollast värvi ja ütlen, et suurte tähtede järgu on siin
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd ma teeksin ee, niimoodi, et ma hakkan alt otsima neid meetodeid niiöelda, mida välja kutsutakse nüüd Mõned meetodid, mis ee, erinevates meetoditest korduvalt võidakse kutsutada. Nagu see need reset succes. Message ja error message. Nad on Common. Selles mõttes erinevad Meetodid võivad neid mingil hetkel kasutada. On ju
Õpetaja: siis niuksed asjad. Ma jätaks üldse niikuinii kõige lõppu, et ma ei tookski nüüd üldse ettepoole, Et mis sest, et Adis kõige esimene meetod, mis siin failis in this file välja. Kutsutakse, On need kaks tükki, Siis need Ma jätaksin kuskile kõige lihtsalt lõppu, Sest et nad on potentsiaalselt niuksed, jagatavad meetodid.
Õpetaja: Kui praegu selle peale klikkida. Ma leian need mõlemad kaks tükki. Ülesanded on juhuslikult kõrvuti Siis praegu. Ma teeks niimoodi, et ma võtaks need katiga ära ja ma ütleks, otsiksin ülesse. Kus kuradi kohas see metsblokk nagu lõpeb. Kõige lihtsam on võibolla klikid selle Methods I peale siin. Niimoodi. Et see joon läheb põlema
Õpetaja: kindlalt. Leian ülesse.
Õpetaja: Kus on tema lõpp. Tema lõpp on siin. Järelikult ma topiksin praegult need kaks meetodit siia lõppu. Näete ta juba selline tühjad read ära
Õpetaja: ja tegi seda siin. Ka sellepärast ma praegult. Ee, Jätaks, Ee, mul oleks koguaeg arusaam, et kuhu maani? Ma olen asjad vaadanud ära. No mis on järgmine Meetod, mida kutsutakse. Välja. Mis on osa sellest Ad Location Ee, meetodist.
Õpetaja: Noh, need ma põhimõtteliselt olen oma järjestuses juba paika pannud, et kus Nad elama hakkavad.
Õpetaja: Checkf form for error. See rida siis minu vaatevinklis võiks olla see esimene meetod, mis tegelikult võiks olla Kohe selle meetodi järgi olete nõus,
Õpetaja: siis ma teeksin niimoodi, et ma nüüd klikin selle peale leian. Selle meetodi ülesse,
Õpetaja: Tulen, võtan selle Cut I ka ära,
Õpetaja: Ja kõige lihtsam on tagasi saada. Kuidas, kus ma just tulin. Niiöelda, kus ma klikkisin, on siis Control alt ja noolekene. Või siis Backspace oma hiire peal
Õpetaja: Kaks korda satun siia. Nüüd on niimoodi, et kutsutakse meetodit, välja mida pole olemas, onju? Aga mina tean, et ma topin selle siis siia, kohe tema järgi.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd ma võtan järgmise meetodi. Siin on selline meetod.
Õpetaja: Fifty Server Messag tuleb Järgmisena. Siis ma olen. Otsin selle ülesse.
Õpetaja: Ma võtan selle Cut I ka ära. Kontroll kaks korda noolt vasakule.
Õpetaja: Tulen siia alla, aga nüüd ma ei saa teda siia alla panna. Vaid ma vaatan, kus see järg on, On ju? Panen siia alla.
Õpetaja: Ma tulen tagasi sinna kohta, kus. Kus see nagu Viimane asi oli, Ahah, Järgmine meetod on see. See on meetod, mis on kutsutud välja kuskil teises failis ei ole siin seda sõna, seda Ma ignoreerin seda. Ei pea, ma ei pea keskenduma.
Õpetaja: Tähendab, Den Block is on järgmine meetod, mida kutsutakse välja Trikin. Selle peale
Õpetaja: tulen võtan selle meetodi Control alt.
Õpetaja: Ee, nool vasakule. Kaks korda Tulen otsin ülesse, kus mu järg on ja topin siia alla
Õpetaja: saab klikkida. Vaata, et Kuhu ma jäin?
Õpetaja: No ma jäin siia.
Õpetaja: Kas siin meetodi sees kutsut? Aa, siin. Ma vaataks ka, et kas siin kutsutakse välja mingid meetodid Seda peab ka jälgima. Sellepärast, et see põhimeetod, Et kutsuda abimeetodi välja. Abimeetod omakorda. Ma vaatan nagu seda järjekorda ka. Vaata, on ju aga praegu lihtsalt sellist olukorda. Siin on see olukord justkui nagu kutsutakse välja. Ja ma võiksin nüüd panna kohe selle meetodi alla,
Õpetaja: et kui ma Tulen seda meetodit lugema. Kutsutakse välja. Siis ma kohe siin all saan seda nagu näha.
Õpetaja: Aga nagu ma ütlesin, et see on niuke potentsiaalne Aa, see on tegelikult ju päris meetod. See pole ju reset message. See on väga spetsiifiline. Sellega
Õpetaja: siis ma lähengi Otsin Ee selle ülesse
Õpetaja: Võtan selle kätte. Control X. Panen Control It nool. Kaks korda vasakule.
Õpetaja: Ahah. Noh, siia alla võiks tulla see, Sest nüüd nad on nagu selles järjekorras. Nüüd ma vaatan seda meetodit. Siin on meetod Get Location Transaction types. Aga see on nüüd selline meetod mida Kutsutakse. Välja tegelikult Ka
Õpetaja: Aa, seal selles. Vaata, noh, see on andmete ära toomine. See on lihtsalt, et ma ei tahaks seda toppida siia, see on nagu meil. On See kolm suurt nuppu, mida saab käivitada
Õpetaja: Transaction types ja Ad Location. Need on nagu peamised need, et seda ma kuskile nagu Mingi random kohta ei paneks, on ju? Noh, siis ma saan aru, et
Õpetaja: sai nagu leidis oma nagu õnneliku lõpu.
Õpetaja: Ee, kukun siia responsi. Noh, see on ka siin. Ei kutsuta rohkem ühtegi meetodit välja. Lähen veel rohkem tagasi. Et Ma jõudsin oma järjega põhimõtteliselt siia
Õpetaja: ja siis Ma võtaksin järgmise meetodi,
Õpetaja: Tulen, võtan selle välja siit nol kaks korda tagasi.
Õpetaja: Tulen otsing. Ee, kus kohas see järg on?
Õpetaja: Ma panen siia maha.
Õpetaja: Ja Ma vaatan, kas siin on mingid meetodid, mida välja kutsutakse Ainukene meetod, mis siin välja kutsutakse, on see aga see ei asus Siinfailist niikuinii.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis ma nagu mõtlen. Okei, sellega. Ma olen ühel pool
Õpetaja: Ad location I Jõudsin kenasti lõppu Okei. Nüüd võiks olla võibolla Siis järgmine Niiöelda nupu vajutus. No need võiks olla siis. Need Mis on seal? Before onju Kõigepealt kutsutakse Get Cities
Õpetaja: Gate Cities
Õpetaja: Ma natuke Nüüd vaatan need kaks tükki on niikuinii järjestikus. Kohe praegult võtaks nad mõlemad ja ma näen, et ta tegelikult ongi juba nagu järg on siin, et ta peab. Enamvähem läheb Okeilt Juba on ju? No ma võtan selle välja Nüüd ma panen ta siia,
Õpetaja: et Get Cities kutsutakse välja. See kutsub selle meetodi. Välja. Siin midagi ei kutsuta välja. Järelikult Gat Cities on nagu ühel pool ja nüüd minu jaoks. Ee, tundub Siit. Järgmine loogiline asi, mis ma teeks, on, on see meetod Get Location Transaction Types. Tulen. Otsin selle meetodi
Õpetaja: Vaatan. Korra Mis peale teda? Noh, kui koodi oled kirjutanud, siis nad juba võivad olla nagu õiges järjekorras. Näete, Need kaks. On õiges järjekorras. Siin midagi ei kutsuta. Need Kaks tükki
Õpetaja: võiks tulla siis siia järje juurde, Tulen alla.
Õpetaja: Noh, need asjad on nüüd omavahel saanud nagu, ee, eduka lõpu
Õpetaja: Nüüd on järgmine Nupp set location long that. Need hakkavad olema juba. Mida Event Id kutsuvad? Välja Event Id kutsuvad välja üks, kaks, kaks. Meetodit on mida Event Id ka kutsuvad välja. Noh, kui selles järjekorras minna siis see võikski olla niiöelda järgmine Niiöelda
Õpetaja: midagi siit välja rohkem ei kutsuta ma võiks ta kinda panna siia?
Õpetaja: Noh, nüüd ma sain aru. Vaata, et ongi tõesti siis mingi järgmine meetod ka Update Location Transaction, et see on nüüd järgmine asi. Mida mingi asi võib Trigerdada? Vaatan, kas siin ma praegu lihtsalt vaatan. Siin all on ka mingid asjad, onju, et Kas mingi meetod siit kutsutakse? Kuskil pole. Tundub, et on nagu Niukene.
Õpetaja: Üksik asi teeb oma tegevuse ära. Ongi kõik
Õpetaja: Transaction Type Selected. Nüüd Ma vaatan, et midagi on järgi jäänud. Need resetid ja asjad ma juba tean, on nüüd võibolla, et oota, aga võibolla mul kuskil on midagi vahele jäänud. Et Kus kuradi kohast seda küsitakse? Selected. Siis ma Lähen Vaatan, kus seda on kutsutud välja.
Õpetaja: Ta oli selle check form For Errors osa. Mul jäi see kahe silma vahele,
Õpetaja: et see meetod kutsub välja seda meetodit, mis on ainult selle meetodiga seotud. No siis Järelikult ta võiks siin all olla, on nii?
Õpetaja: Noh, siis ma lähen klikin sinna alla. Just, ma tulin sealt kohast. Võtan selle siit niimoodi Cuti ka ära. Lähen Control altanool vasakule. Kaks korda, et sinna kohta, kus ma jäin, vaatan, kus koeraduse meetod lõppeb ja panen ta selle lihtsalt siia
Õpetaja: kuidagi umbes nii. Ja okei. Vahel On nagu see, et sul on mingi shareitud meetodid. Sa ühel hetkel ei taba ära et Sa hakkad ühte asja mitu korda tõstma. Edasi tagasi. Saad aru, et. Aa, okei. Seda on mingi kahes kohas, et ta ei pea olema perfektne, aga ta võiks olla võimalikult perfektne. Noh, samamoodi ma nüüd saan teha need varasemad võ võlad korda, mis on,
Õpetaja: Ee, tuleb. Vaatame mis Siin on,
Õpetaja: ee, mitte login service, vaid Login View.
Õpetaja: See siin. Panen muud asjad üldse kinni. Kõrvalt.
Õpetaja: No siin. Ma vaatan ka ka korra Nüüd, et võtsime selle lähenemise, et äkki see, kui on before, võiks olla ülevalpool, aga siin polegi Vaata, on ju? Teen metsads bloki lahti,
Õpetaja: Ee, võibolla üritan aru saada. Vaata, et. Ee, mis siin üldse saab? Siin ongi ainult see Login nupp. See on peameetod. See on ainukene asi, mis on siin klikitav. Ee, siin failis. Niiöelda ta on siin. Näete siin nupu küljes, on nii,
Õpetaja: Siis ma lihtsalt mõtleks, et okei, Tema on kõige tähtsam to do meetodi erarhia.
Õpetaja: Ja ma vaatan, et ee,
Õpetaja: siin ongi tegelikult kõik ainult selle meetodiga seotud. Siin võib isegi järjekorras Minna Ee, reset error message.
Õpetaja: Noh, see võiks olla siis selle järgi teen võibolla samamoodi siia. Selle ee, tudu järg,
Õpetaja: Noh, et kuidagi Nagu hoida nagu visuaalselt.
Õpetaja: Tulen siit eest. Login kutsub välja reset Terror Message. Mis ta järgmisena välja kutsub? Resetterror Message. Midagi ise ei kutsu välja.
Õpetaja: Niukene Asi tundub, et ta tegelikult ongi juba enamvähem järjekorras. Panen selle siia alla.
Õpetaja: Lähen tagasi sinna kohta. Kus seda välja kutsutakse. Järgmisena on Start, Spinner.
Õpetaja: Noh, ta juba tuleb. Mulle tundub, et see järjekorda ennast on lihtsam nagu panna Nii,
Õpetaja: tulen ülesse, vaatan Järgmisena kutsutakse meetodid, Mis kuskil mujal siis tuleb? Response kutsub välja meetodid. Save
Õpetaja: Response info to Session Storage. Ma näen. See on Siin kohe all. Järelikult mul tasuks need kaks tükki võtta. Panen ta lihtsalt siia
Õpetaja: järje sisse ja vaatan järgmist asja.
Õpetaja: Pealegi saad klikkida. Vaata, et kust see läheb. See läheb siia,
Õpetaja: Kuhu see läheb? See läheb siia järelikult selle asja ma olen ära lahendanud.
Õpetaja: Järgmine on,
Õpetaja: tulen. Võtan selle meetodi Võibolla korra piilun. Vaata, kas siin, Kutsutakse Disiga mõnda meetodit välja. Ainult muutujad. On. Tundub et midagi rohkem ei ole. Klikin korra siia. Vaatan, kus ta algab, Kus ta lõpeb?
Õpetaja: Võtan ta Cuti ka ära.
Õpetaja: Tulen panen siia järgi. Nüüd ongi alles jäänud. Stop, spinner. Kui vaadata, siis on ka niimoodi siin, et finalis
Õpetaja: selles meetodis kutsutakse meetodeid välja. Siin on siis topspinner.
Õpetaja: Kui mul oleks siin olnud mingisugused meetodid veel, mis jagavad seda start And stop spinner It. Topiksin nad kuskile lihtsalt alla,
Õpetaja: et nad ei ole. Ei Tule niimoodi järjekorras Aga ma tean siis, et asjad on mul seal kuskil all. Ja siin on ka jällegi. Vaata, ega see, mis mina nagu räägin. Selline lähenemine. Ee, ei ole nüüd nagu mingisugune Absoluutne tõde. Kuidas seda peaks tegema?
Õpetaja: Aga kui me läheme näiteks Jaavasse, siis seal on. Siis seal on niuksed, reeglid, Kõik Public. Meetodid tulevad Kõigepealt
Õpetaja: ei ole niimoodi, et tuleb meetod. Private meetod. Private meetod, Public meetod. Private Private Nagu siin. Teeme, on ju? Seal. On esialgne Reegel on väga lihtne. Ainult public meetodid. Meetodid võiksid tulla siis noh, mis iganes Järjekorras
Õpetaja: Ee või kui neid kuskilt mujalt kutsutakse välja, siis võibolla selles järjekorras. Aga Siis ma teen niimoodi. Vaata, et kui mul on üks public meetod, mis kutsub välja viis erinevat private meetodit, siis ma Teen küll niimoodi. Kõige Esimene public meetod,
Õpetaja: mis mul seal nende public meetodite seas on, et ma otsin ülesse, mis on esimene private meetod,
Õpetaja: Niiöelda, mis on seotud selle teenusega. Ja ma panen selle sinna public meetodite alla. Ja nüüd ma hakkan vaatama, et nüüd, kõik selle public meetodi abimeetodid tulevad järjest ja seal samamoodi kui üks meetod kutsub. Abimeetod kutsub veel mingi oma abi Meetod? Ma panen sellesse järjekorda Miks,
Õpetaja: kui sa koodi. Nüüd, kui ma kujutage ette, et ma nüüd klikin näiteks siia.
Õpetaja: Hea küll, ta ei olnud nüüd kohe siin all sellepärast, et Ta Ei saa olla järjekorra mõttes, Aga nüüd vähemalt praegult siin. Kui ma vaataksin. Aa, mis see loogiline respons teeb, et kõigepealt me väärtustame Ära mingi muutuja. Saame selle kuskilt tatast. Seejärel kutsutakse välja See võib loogiline respons. Info to session storage. Siis limitakse. Siis minnakse ära.
Õpetaja: Oota, Aga mis see, kuidas see see blogi respons to
Õpetaja: info Decession stores. Et Mida see täpsemalt siis teeb? Noh, see on siin samas all
Õpetaja: Saate mõttest aru. Ja, noh, inimesed on oma erineval tasemel. Vaata, on ju kui kuidas keegi oma riidekapis asjad järjest või sahtlis näiteks onju, Mõnel on kõik segamini. Ee, mõnel on ikka mingi piinliku täpsusega. Mingi tulevad kõigepealt mingi pikkusega asjad Suurusega Asjad Värviga asjad.
Õpetaja: Noh, et mina, Olen nagu pigem selline, et ma olen see. Vaata, et mul ei ole mingit probleemi Jätta. Kapiuksti lahti ja taldrikud kuhugi laua peale, et Ee, Niukene friik. Ma ei ole. Vaata, et ma enda ära koristan. See on mu naine naise teema jälle, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga kui ma Teen mingisuguseid asju ja ma hakkan korralikult tegema. Alles hiljutasin. Tegin oma riidekapi täiesti ilusti korda. Kõik Särgid tulid nagu niimoodi ilusti värvid järjekorras
Õpetaja: heledamatest pihta. Vaata ja siis vaikselt sujuvad tulevad värvid. Värvid omavahel nagu haakuvad, et tuleb sinna sinine. Siis tulevad roheline. Noh, inimesed on erinevad On ju, et, ee, minule ikkagi tegelikult meeldib, et on süsteem, Sest et siis ma tean, kuidas. Nagu ka asju kuskilt otsida või vaadata,
Õpetaja: Noh, see on nii. Ja naa. Vaata, kui sa pead hakkama siit millegiga niimoodi sõitma. Niimoodi, vaata.
Õpetaja: Jaa, mul on. Pole.
Õpetaja: No Vaata, see on Jälle see. Vaata, et siis, Collaps. Iga. Sa ei näe alammeetodeid. Vaata, kui sul on, ütleme, niimoodi. Et siis on ikkagi, kui sul on Kõik asjad on Collaps. Ma võin ka seda teha, onju? Et võtan selle, Tulen siia peale ja ütlen Ee Collaps,
Õpetaja: et ta nagu Teised meetodid ka, onju? Teen korra lahti. Mul on need meetodid siin nüüd reas ja. Niimoodi. On, noh, niimoodi nagu sa mõtlesid, onju
Õpetaja: Ee? Noh, lihtsalt see. See Downside on see, et sa ei näe meetodi sisse. Vaata, et sa pead siis nimede järgi, nagu saama selle. Paika Vaata, kui sul on abimeetod, kutsub abimeetodi ja see meetod kutsub veel omakorda, on ju Aga kui tekstina nagu kõnetab ja on hästi, siis Saab nii ka hakkama, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, bottomline on see, et peaasi, et saab asi korda. Noh, mul on ei tea, liigutasin siin. Mingeid asju veel.
Õpetaja: No vaadake. Noh,
Õpetaja: kirjeldab loo kinni ju. Praegult, onju? Spinner. See nüüd kuidagi liikus siin. Sellega. Mul ära vaata, onju? Tegelikult see on Lõpus to session Storage.
Õpetaja: Ee, see siis tuule siia.
Õpetaja: Noh, saab isegi nimede järgi ka. Niimoodi tõesti, onju
Õpetaja: Ülikama. Ole siis Ms. I Messi Grisi,
Õpetaja: kui tahad kohe, et selles mõttes, Ee. Ei, tehniliselt ei ole. Vahet pole, Ükstaspuha.
Õpetaja: Aa, aga ütlengi näiteks, et, ee, kui Back endist Näiteks, et keegi võib. Seal Võibolla ei hakka nokkima. Aa, seal Gold Reviews, et sul on näiteks mingid meetodid tagu tagurpidi järjekorras, et üks on seal ennem defineeritud ja teine teine teine. Nagu järjekord, on oma omavahel kutsumise mõttes vastupidine. Vaata, kui seal, nagu keegi sellega ei hakka midagi seal ütlema.
Õpetaja: Aga kui sul on näiteks see, et. Ee, et sul on uuesti public meetod, siis seal juba tuleb. Juba. Code Reviews kiri. Vaata, et Kuule, see on. See on jaava tava. See pole nagu kokku lepitud tava, vaid see ongi Kuidas jaavas käib
Õpetaja: tehnilises mõttes On seal ka ülisavi. Kõik töötab. Mingit vahet pole.
Õpetaja: Kompileeritav kood ka veel peale kauba
Õpetaja: Ee, et umbes umbes niimoodi. Ee, Noh, seda. Kõike saab delegeerida. Tegelikult ka väga ilusti. Tegelikult. Chatch Ip It Cloud. Ile, et ütlevad, et palun nagu järjest meetodid väljakutsumise,
Õpetaja: Lähme edasi
Õpetaja: ja seal ta juba teab. Vaata, et nagu ja Nii, edasi. Vaata, et mingi veel lihtsam on. Teed mingi skill I, et ta teed sellise skill I, et küsi minult faili nime. Mina teen korda. Noh, see on korduvtegevus ju.
Õpetaja: Nagu et palun pane hierarhilisse järjekorda, et kui see on nagu Selline asi, millega sinul meeldib toimetada. Vaata, see ongi see koht ka. Kus. Saad siis ise veel lahti kirjutada? Et Täpselt kuidas. Vaata, sa mõtled, Vaata ka mingit ee, täiendusi. Noh, see on nüüd nagu see värvide värk. Vaata, et tahad võibolla mingi väga konkreetselt, kuidas sul See on
Õpetaja: iga kord, kui teed oma töö ära. Lihtsalt siis lõpus ütled. Nagu toit annab faili nimedele ette.
Õpetaja: Ma nii tegingi kusjuures ka Nüüd vi viimases projektis, et nagu viitsinud enam niimoodi üles alla, nagu isegi tõsta. No veelgi parem. On see, kui sa paned juhenditesse, et Kui sa lood uue meetodi, vaata siis kohe. Ei, järgi seda, Aga ma ütlen, See on see sama küsimus. Jaroslav vist küsis, et kui Hästi, Ta nagu seda suudab jälgida. Vaata neid soove ja asju, et noh, me ei suuda. Vaata vahepeal ikkagi,
Õpetaja: ee, et ongi see, et Kui sa tahad üldistesse juhistesse panna. See on jälle lisainformatsioon, millega ta peab arvestama. Mida rohkem, seal Staffi on, seda keerulisem tal tegelikult on seda järgida, et. Noh, lihtsam on üks kill, onju? Ise hoiad meeles
Õpetaja: või sa paneksid lihtsalt selle kasvõi niimoodi? Vaatad, et peale igasuguse meetodi lisamist. Vaata klasside tegemist. Palun jooksutage see skill siis. Tal on vähemalt nagu vähem informatsiooni, et sa ei pea seal midagi väga kirjeldama sõnadega, vaid. Sa viitad sellele skill ile
Õpetaja: nii.
Õpetaja: Noh, see on nagu enamvähem korras Proovida ka korra. Kuskil see mul ei olnud kommititud, onju? Vaatame Praegult on siis nagu Niukene järjekord. Ma Korraback in selle
Õpetaja: log in view rolback.
Õpetaja: Ee, võtan Cloud i lahti ee Cloud
Õpetaja: ja ütlen talle
Õpetaja: Vaatan korra mõned faili nime. Copy, Copy Bath. Ee, mõnda faili ette. Ütlen, et ee. Palun järjest meetodid
Õpetaja: välja Kutsumise Aa, Nüüd tuleb raske sõna hierarhias, entera või tuli vigast tuli.
Õpetaja: Noh, vaatame, kas saab sellega hakkama või Mitte
Õpetaja: loogiline on tipptasand selle järgi järgnevad selle poolt otsa kutsutud abimeetodid ning kõige lõpus
Õpetaja: lehed, bla, bla, blabla plaan. No vaatame, mis ta teeb. Vaata,
Õpetaja: lase ta selle ära teha. Nad kirjutab ülevaate mulle ka
Õpetaja: sama järjekord Kõige sama järjekorva.
Õpetaja: Selles mõttes pole Midagi keerulist. Pean mitte midagi tegema.
Õpetaja: Mul üldse seda vaja õpetat oleks, aga ma tegelikult, tahaks et te saaksite aru ka Vaata, tegelt, ega? Noh, ma ise. Kui ma ikkagi koodi kirjutan, nagu ise kirjutan koodi, siis ma Ikkagi tegelikult seda juba kirjutamise ajal. Veits nagu jälgin, oleneb. Vaata, kui ma praegu siin õpetan teid kuus nädalat, siis ma ei viitsi. Vaata Lihtsalt niimoodi. Sellel hetkel, nagu,
Õpetaja: ee, tegeleda sellega. Aga kuhu ma ise koodi kirjutan? Ee, siis ma ikkagi Pigem nagu jälgin seda. Vaata, et Kas tuleb juba Kohe, järjest?
Õpetaja: Aga või Vähemalt ma nagu kindlalt seda niiöelda viimistluse hetkel nii öelda. Noh, koristas selle kommentaari ka ära, Väga Tubli, Noh, Ma ei tea, kas siin kuskil veel on. Midagi.
Õpetaja: Ee, Vaatame, mis views. Võibolla on midagi vä.
Õpetaja: No siin mõned meetodid ma Siis ütlen nüüd juba. See vestlus on olemas. Ee,
Õpetaja: siis ma võin öelda ka, et ee. Ka.
Õpetaja: Noh, tõsisse ka
Õpetaja: töötajaid. Aja maha, võtan Ma ise ka mõnikord Exceliga, et. Noh, mingi hetk Ma ei taha. Joonistan kastide ilu Pealt.
Õpetaja: Väike siuke kontroll. Vaata, kinnistamine on ju muidugi, Noh,
Õpetaja: et, noh, see. See kain taga isegi tundub. Vaata, nagu, et kui ütleme, kui see kood on nagu ilusti niiöelda tehtud, vaata see Sinu lähenemis. Sa mõtlesid. Vaata, et ee. Foldid kõik ära, onju? Ma korra, foldin nad kõik siin selle ee, peal Folding.
Õpetaja: Kõik, mis siin all on? Vaata, on, et ka tegelikult. Kui. Kui see oleks niimoodi ilusti tehtud, Vaata, kui keegi teine tuleks, siis saaks võibolla ka päris kiirelt pildi jätta. Nagu et mis siin? Nagu toimub, et Locations midagi. Noh, midagi nagu näiteks siukest ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, kõige tähtsam ongi siin. Ee, Selles mõttes, ee. Siin Selles Htms is võiks tõsta ka ära, et Control iks, et lepime kokku, et edaspidi ta pigem on kohe siin üleval.
Õpetaja: Noh, teeks niimoodi. Näiteks Davai. Aitab, Ee, aitab sellest jamast. Feb üksteist Complete.
Õpetaja: Liigume muudele jahimaadele.
Õpetaja: Nii nagu sai välja reklaamitud. Aa, mis Mis me nüüd teeme, kui kõik on valmis?
Õpetaja: Merchime niiöelda ära, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, teil ei ole. Ma ütlen, et kui keegi tahab kuidagi järgi tulla, siis ma mörtsin need rahulikult õpetajasse ära. Võite kustutada enda. Ee, selle arenduse.
Õpetaja: Aa, mine tea tehke, kuidas Soovite Mis ma siin Ikka ütlen, mis te tegema peate.
Õpetaja: Kus on igal juhul tehtud.
Õpetaja: Nii kui nii varem või hiljem tulete või teisel hetkel järgi, et kui praegu teeb midagi tegemata.
Õpetaja: Külla Järgi tulete
Õpetaja: nii. Ee, Mina igal juhul mersin siis selle õpetaja sisse. Selle jaoks ma lähen sinna. Vot see Ongi uus asi By the way et, Merch Imisel see Käib õpetaja suunas vanasti. Oli niimoodi et, sa pidid tegema checkout i ära Ja minema selle haru peale, kus tahad Merch ida.
Õpetaja: Aga minu meelest praegu saab isegi niimoodi. Et ma nagu näitan, näed, et O mul on Niukene Haru nagu õpetaja.
Õpetaja: Aga see on valetpidi ju. Ma pean ikkagi minema. Mida Ma joon koguaeg. Olen rääkinud Bullsüsteem. Kuidas järsku nüüd saaks Nagu teistmoodi. Ee, ei, ma pean ikkagi minema selle haru. Peale seda enam ka, et võib Merch konflikt tekkida. Tegelikult kuidas sa seda lahendad, Kui selle haru peal pole,
Õpetaja: Ee, veeb üksteist into õpetaja. Ja. Ja teie ärge õpetajasse Merchige.
Õpetaja: No juba nägin. Evely oli seal komite teinud Juba õpetaja Arus tahtis nüüd roheline. Noolekene oli, et sinna lähevad kohe teele.
Õpetaja: Ei, ei, lähe. Kustutasin selle haru ära. Lihtsalt uuesti.
Õpetaja: Ee, tavaliselt alati. Keegi on mulle midagi sinna Masteris. Ee, mergend. Ja et see on
Õpetaja: tavaliselt kui keegi selle vea teeb, siis terve kursuse lihtsalt siin Seal saab tegeleda.
Õpetaja: Kahjuks keegi ei ole seda viga teinud. Täitsa olen isegi pettunud.
Õpetaja: No viimasel hetkel vä. Ee, ei, see on fun. Alati, Kui see juhtub ja on fun, Vaata, kui see tuleb välja kahel võimalikul viisil.
Õpetaja: Üks on see. Vaata, et inimene saab ise aru ja Siis nagu näed, et. Oi, ma väga palun vabandust. Vaata nagu nulli Savi. Kaotan selle ära. Või siis teine variant. Kui ma avastan selle, Vaata,
Õpetaja: ma nagu lähen oma haru peale tulen. Vaatan nagu, Oo, õpetaja. Mingid muudatused on serverist olemas. Mingi kaasarendaja. Noh, vaatame seda tööd, siis On see hea üldse?
Õpetaja: Seal? Nime loomulikult. Saab ju kitlog Ist. Kohe kätte onju? Halvemal juhul. Muidugi on inimene, ei ole muutnud oma kit Name I ära. Ja selle arvutiga on õpetaja või õpilane? Vabandust
Õpetaja: siis on natuke keerulisem, aga tavaliselt on ikkagi mingi nimi olnud.
Õpetaja: Saab kõik naerda.
Õpetaja: Ei, mul ei ole igav. Ärge selle pärast magatsege.
Õpetaja: Ee, järgmine asi on siis ee, modal. Ee, sa nüüd korra vaatamise kohta lihtsalt meelde tuletada. Eile korra rääkisime
Õpetaja: millise asja nimi on Madal.
Õpetaja: Ee, ee. Mingi Esimesed kolm, neli gruppi. Ma Isegi ei valland seda kunsti.
Õpetaja: Ee, Ütleme niimoodi. Ee, et selline selline nagu asi, mida me siin näeme, annab infosüsteemis hoopis. Teistsuguse paindlikkuse juurde. Me ei Pea alati nagu sellel Samal lehel mingit peitme asju kuvama.
Õpetaja: Näiteks, et tahad midagi lisada väikest juurde või viima tingimata uuele vaatele, et see on ka Option, aga Siin on üks konks, on mida peab arvestama. Ärge nüüd nagu modaliga väga hulluks minge.
Õpetaja: Aa, mudelil on ikka. Omad. Id ka nagu Kõigel Ee, on. Igal asjal on mingi omad plussid miinused.
Õpetaja: Kui te teete niukseid madaleid. Ee, mis siis võtavad ka mingeid sisendeid, et saad sinna kastisse kirjutada Või mingit palju Action It on, et saad klikkida. Kasutaja telefonis madal tihtipeale. Võibolla kõige paremini ei toimi.
Õpetaja: Sa võid mööda klikkida, Ta läheb kinni.
Õpetaja: Paigutused asjad võivad minna tegelikult kuidagi nihu. Vaata, et igasuguseid asju võib juhtuda, et natuke nagu tuleb modaliga, nagu mõelda ka Vaata, et
Õpetaja: kui ta midagi kuvab ja mingi, siis ta on Niukene Suht hea asi, vaata mida kasutada. Kui sinna modalisse tuleb mingi monster Vorm, mida peab ära täitma koos väljade. Ega siis mina seda ei teeks. Tee juba siis parem eraldi vaade, on eks? Lihtsam on
Õpetaja: ee, et Siin on igast asju ka. Pluss Back back. Nupp
Õpetaja: on nagu see ee kasutaja. Kui teeb mingi suure modeli lahti, kus on mingi Suur vaade. Ja seal on veel mingi Next ja Previous. Seal Mingid nupud veel ka veel. Jumal teab. Vaata, mis justkui viitaks, Kui kasutaja Ee, avab mudali siis ta ei liigu uuele vaatele. Ta on seal samas vaates.
Õpetaja: Kui ta vajutab Back nuppu, siis ta läheb. Noh, nagu Browser. Kas hiirel või või seal Browserist. Vahet pole, siis ta, läheb, kuhu iganes ta ennem tuli, et kasutaja mõte võibolla oli, et panna modal kinni ja näha nagu seda, mida ta ennem nägi. Aga kui ta vajutabki, siis ei juhtu see vaid juhtub see.
Õpetaja: Sa lähed eelmisele lehele, et siin on niuksed. Aspektid, mida peab mõtlema. Modal, ei vii sind uuele lehele. Noh, taustal on ikka ju see sama purl üleval, Vaata, Noh, panen kinni. On How It Works
Õpetaja: on siis demo, kes me oleme kuhugi mujale läinud? Ei ole, Panen kinni, vaid, on, Noh, ei tee midagi, See on Close Paneb kinni,
Õpetaja: Me ei lähe. Kuu Vaade ei muutu. Sellega tuleb arvestada.
Õpetaja: Ee, et seal on omad Id, et kui ma ikka ise tegin seda klassiraha süsteemi väljavaatega, Et, ee, noh, mina ei tea. Minu Ee, klassivanemad saaksid seda Kasutada. Võtame kasutusele Aa, siis siis ma sain aru, kohe, et ee, et niukestes kohtades sa pead natukene rohkem mõtlema, nagu. Vaata, et ära kasuta madalit liiga Liberaalselt.
Õpetaja: Pluss.
Õpetaja: Ee. See variant on ka. Kui te lähete seda teed pidi, et te tahate teha mingit modalit, kus saab siis seal täita mingisuguseid asju ja värke. Kui te juba ühe korra ühe modali avate,
Õpetaja: siis te võite oma disainis minna niipsesse kohta vaata, et seal modali peal. Täidate midagi Ja siis. On nagu täpselt niuke koht. Kui hea oleks, et nüüd siin kohas saaks vajutada nupu ja tuleks lahti modal
Õpetaja: Aga sul juba modal ongi lahti. Jah, tehniliselt. Sa saad nüüd teha, et tuleb veel üks modal lahti. Kus kana peidad? Ära vaata või Või paned kinni lausa või mis iganes,
Õpetaja: Aga te tegelikult võtate endale. Iga kord, kui te kasutate Madalit, siis te peate ka sellega arvestama, Et et sellist lahendust ikka ei tasu teha. Vaata, et nüüd, kui sellest disainis kuskil ka seal, tegelikult oleks hea veel kasutaja, saaks korra midagi näha või vaadata või teha. Vaata, on ju. Siis te võtate. Võibolla võtate selle võimaluse ära või te peate hakkama tegema seda mingit Imelikku disaini või lahendust.
Õpetaja: Ja kui mõelda päriselus, et kuidas kogu see asi veel ka mobiilis kokku mängib,
Õpetaja: ühe madali teed lahti, äkki kasuta Kogemata vajuta. Üks Madal tuleb lahti. Teine Madal tuleb lahti. Kasuta, mõtleb. Ei, ei, paneb hiirega.
Õpetaja: Nagu et see, sellega tuleb hästi natukene, nagu, Sest et ta on väga mõnus asi ja tal on kindlasti oma koht olemas.
Õpetaja: Ee, noh, ikka näete ka neid siukseid Asju ikka näete, On ju, et, ee, et sellel on oma koht olemas. Aga tuleb natukene nagu mõelda ka nagu igasugustele potensiaalsetele probleemidele ette juba, et kas Tahad nendega tegeleda või
Õpetaja: või mitte. Ja kasutajakogemus. No, rääkisime seda ka arvutimängudes. Vaata, et
Õpetaja: vaata. Mänguloojad nagu Mõtlevad. Et kuidas mingit mängu nagu mängima peaks. Vaata, siis tuleb mingisugune tohutu mass peale Ja nemad hakkavad väga teistmoodi mõtlema. Samamoodi, et jah. Teie arenduse käigus nagu disainite mingisuguse asja. Vaata, kuidas kasutaja peaks seda kasutama.
Õpetaja: Aga kasutaja ei pruugi näiteks aru saada, et kuidas teie olete seda asja mõelnud. See on, see on üldse halb disain. Ee, kui sa ei saa aru, mida ma järgmisena tegema pean, siis tegelikult. Aa on halvasti. Mina olen ise kokku puutunud ka niukeste asjadega, Kus ma
Õpetaja: tee mingisugust asja ma tegelt ei ole absoluutselt õrna aimu. Vaata, mis nüüd edasi tegema. See on halvasti Disainitud Ee, süsteem.
Õpetaja: Intuitiivne peab olema see sõna, mida me otsime. Vaata, on ju, et kasutaja ise. Kohe saab kohe aru vaata peale vaadates Saab aru, mida siin teha saab, Kuidas siin teha saab ja Nii edasi, jah, see võib olla mingi väga keeruline süsteem, mis teeb mingi Väga keerulisi asju. Vaata, kus. Võibolla on siis mingi
Õpetaja: küsimärgid juures, et kus saad mingeid nagu tuultippe ja asju, et nagu et sa saad teda nagu aidata. Vaata, et, noh, kahjuks ongi keeruline asi Kahjuks seda ei olegi võimalik teha. Nagu. Nagu, täiesti, nagu et niimoodi vaatad peale Ja oskad kohe kasutada. Aga siis sa saad vähemalt nagu tema abistamiseks mõelda. Mingisugused nipid ja trikid. Vaata, et kuidas
Õpetaja: ta ikkagi tegelikult hätta ei jää, vaata, onju? Ta saab aru, et. Okei, Ee, ma ei saa kohesest asjadest, aru, aga ma vähemalt saan aru Vaata, et kust Ma natukene saan mingit lisainfot. Ja kuidas ma lõpuks selle asja ära täidan või? Või teen? On ju,
Õpetaja: et see on täiesti omaette teadus huviks ja huvi. Vaata üldse. Vaata, user Experience, Vaata, kuidas. Ta nagu, Aa, kuidas ta käib? Mis moodi ta nagu asju näeb, kas ta See ongi see ka, et teil tihtipeale kui teed oma töid, siis te tahate mõnes kohas teha ühe mõned asjad ühe sammuga ära.
Õpetaja: Aga Mina tulen, ütlen kohe. Nagu Kuulge, teeme nüüd siin selle. Selle protsessi Teeme kahesammuliseks,
Õpetaja: et. Ee, siin on. Lihtsalt ee. Mingisugused Ee,
Õpetaja: Ee, probleemid, Mis teid ees ootavad? Kui te teete, saate teha siin kõik ühe sammuga. Noh, see on see, et veel kogemust nii palju pole, Vaata Nii et teeme nagu siin, et samamoodi jällegi
Õpetaja: omaette teadvus. Vaata, et kuidas. Kuidas. Nagu Kasutaja. Flow kuskil peaks olema, kuidas ta oleks nagu Võimalikult hea, võimalikult lihtne, Võimalikult vähe Vigu tuleks võimalikult. Ma ei mõtle pugisi Vaata vaid kasutajapoolseid vigu,
Õpetaja: asju et see on omaette ooper et Ma kujutan ette, et ee mingid suuremad ettevõtted ikkagi on ikka väga palju pappi pannud selle. Peale Vaata, et nagu ja aega ja energiat, Et läbi mõelda. Vaata, kuidas nendes süsteemis ee, kasutaja saaks toimetada, et see oleks võimalikult mugav, lihtne ja töökindel ja veatu arusaadav.
Õpetaja: Noh, mida Rohkem tarbijaid on Seda rohkem. On ju võimalust. Noh, see sama mängu näide
Õpetaja: mass lendab peale ja hakkab seal asju tegema ja tulevad kugid Tulevad katki, tulevad kirjad postkastides. Ee, inimene ei mõista ja nii edasi. Aa sooviks kõike seda vältida.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on siis meie plaan.
Õpetaja: Aa, Aga meie plaan on nüüd selline.
Õpetaja: See funktsionaalsus, Et ee.
Õpetaja: Tuleb lahti. Niukene aken ja tuleb mingisugune title. Tuleb mingisugune sisu. See ei pea ainult tekst olema. Ee mingisugused nupud. See saab olema meie. Niiöelda
Õpetaja: me oma meie lahendus. Me teeme asju niimoodi, et me ei korda koodi
Õpetaja: sellise asja funktsionaalsuse Niiöelda kirjutamine võtab juba üksjagu ridu, et lihtsalt tekitada sellist agent.
Õpetaja: Meie tahame teha niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Et me võtame lihtsalt ühe korra Teeme selle akna
Õpetaja: Failin ära. Ma võin korra. Teen trend i lahti.
Õpetaja: Me tahame teha niimoodi seda, et, ee, me ühe korra teeme selle Funktsionaalsuse osa kõik ära. Ja siis, mis me teeme, on see, et me tekitame.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma mõtlen, tekitame pesa.
Õpetaja: Noh, teeme siia natukene liiga Suurelt on mahu ära. Siia
Õpetaja: ikka. Teate mis pesa on, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, loomulikult linnupesa.
Õpetaja: Aga Päris linnupesa me siin ei mõtle
Õpetaja: nagu šlott väike sõna.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, mida iganes me tahame teha sellise asja, et kogu see asi suures pildis niiöelda toimib
Õpetaja: ja meie saame seda sama Niiöelda,
Õpetaja: ee, seda sama. Niiöelda faili. Seda sama lahendust Saame lihtsalt korduvalt uuesti ja uuesti kasutada Ka ei tea, Näiteks nagu template
Õpetaja: Ee, ja See on meie enda vaba voli, mis tuleb siia, mis tuleb siia. Kuidas
Õpetaja: ka enda Nagu vormi? Jah,
Õpetaja: ee. Ja mis tuleb siia, et Kas siia tuleb mingisugune tekst? Niisama tuleb tekst siia. Äkki hoopis mingi motikoniga? Mingi ikooniga taital? Mida iganes, Body osas. Pilt, Tulp, kast
Õpetaja: ee, Link Radio Button Checkbox.
Õpetaja: Mis veel, mida iganes, mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Jah, mida iganes. Nagu põhimõtteliselt Si, et see, et meil on nagu see kast olemas. See funktsionaalsus tuleb ette ja ristis saab kinni panna. Varjundid, värgid, kõik kõik, kõik selle. Me teeme ainult ühe korra, Aga me teeme selle niimoodi Vaata, et sinna sisse tekivad väiksed pesad
Õpetaja: ja meil on võimalik nüüd seda plotsi põhimõtteliselt igal pool kasutada
Õpetaja: ja anda talle lihtsalt Sisendina kaasa
Õpetaja: Mingi teistsugune sisu. Aga kui me siiamaani oleme niiöelda rääkinud, niiöelda, et taas teeme ühe klotsi ja anna sisu. Noh, näiteks see Citystrop Down, onju?
Õpetaja: Klotsvana sisu.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis me veel tegime? Tegime selle Location formi. Kus sees on? Mingid asjad. Anname sisu. Tegime selle Transaction Types checkboxide, mis on oma klass ja annab sisu. Aga vaata seal. Me anname sisu Kui lihtsalt andmed visuaalse poole pealt Html elemente ei teki juurde ega vähene.
Õpetaja: Need asjad, mis on nendes klotsides, on
Õpetaja: nagu põhimõtteliselt ee Html i osas nii öelda template osas visuaalsete elementide osas See ei muutu. Aga nüüd me räägime just sellest,
Õpetaja: et me. Meil on selline võimalus selles tehnoloogias, et me saame teha tegelikult endale mingisuguse malli või asja.
Õpetaja: Aga meil on võimalus seda asja siis kasutada. Niimoodi, et me. Kas kirjutame seal mingid asju? Mingisugused asjad, nagu
Õpetaja: paneme laksame lihtsalt üle nagu Või paneme lihtsalt oma niiöelda oma sisu, et kujutame ette Näiteks, Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, võibolla mingisugune. Näiteks nagu mingi bänner või mingisugune asi või mingi kaardivärk. Vaata, et meil näitame mingisuguseid tooteid. Ja seal kuskil näidatakse mingit pilte asju, mis iganes tahame kõike seda, mis seal on, aga me tahame võibolla variatsiooni.
Õpetaja: Ee, et võibolla siin mõne asja juures ongi hoopis ka kohe mingisugune link Või mingisugune täiesti muu asi. Vaata,
Õpetaja: midagi on natukene juures, et siis me ei taha teha niimoodi, et juhtub seda, et kõik see osa, mis tegelikult kogu aeg enda Nagu kordub, kordub, kordub aga väikse visuaalse erinevusega, et me kogu aeg kirjutame uuesti ja uuesti ja uuesti
Õpetaja: seda sama ühisosa uuesti ehk me Ei taha teha eraldi niiöelda Niiöelda Madalifaile kogu selle funktsionaalsuse Staffiga uuesti ja uuesti ja uuesti.
Õpetaja: Me ei taha seda korrata seda disaini, me ei taha neid X asju me ei taha teha. Ma ütlengi. Me praegu vaatame seda madali kontekstis, Vaata, kus on ülimalt loogiline seda niimoodi teha, Aga mõtleme ka lihtsalt üleüldiselt arenduses. Kujutame ette, et teil ongi nagu mingisugune visuaalne asi,
Õpetaja: Mis teie infosüsteemis ühel või teisel viisil tahab Nagu korduda, aga natukene erinevad. Mitte andmed, vaid erinevad.
Õpetaja: Siis ongi teil see tööriist. Te saate teha selle ühisosa ühe korra ära
Õpetaja: panna sinna väiksed pesad sisse. Ja nüüd on nagu tšillipilli. Iga kell saad kasutada seda klotsi. Ee niiöelda selle osaga, mis seal on, aga juurde omad Erinevused vastavas kohast, nii nagu vaja.
Õpetaja: Ülivõimas värist.
Õpetaja: Keegi ütles. Selle sõna jõuab ära. Zlot. Kes ütles seda?
Õpetaja: No väga hea, Teadsid või Lihtsalt Ütlesid Pesashlot?
Õpetaja: Jah, sellepärast lihtsalt siin kirjaviisis tulebki. Niukene asi jõuda nagu väikene. Noh, pilu,
Õpetaja: nagu siin ongi. Vaata, on Slot pesa.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma ei tea, sõlunis.
Õpetaja: Väga hea.
Õpetaja: Kellega saab luua, on erinevaid.
Õpetaja: Mis me nüüd siis tahame teha, on see, et, ee, me kõigepealt. Ee, me Saaksime võtta selle Koodi, mis on siin, aga see on puhas Css lahendus.
Õpetaja: Ee ehk siis suures pildis. Meil on siin modal, aga et seda niiöelda Voe funktsionaalsusega panna, et kui vajutad nupu kinni, lähed kinni ja Nii, edasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma ei tahaks seda nullist võtta ja hakata teiega modifitseerima, Vaid ma rotiks selle eelmisest projektist ära. Samamoodi nagu me tegime. Aa Input image iga. No see nupukene. Vaata, ja ma lihtsalt Räägin läbi, kuidas mis toimib. Seal sobib teile selline lähenemine,
Õpetaja: et ärme kuluta nagu aega sellele nii palju.
Õpetaja: Ee, võtan korra siis eelmise grupi lahti. Ma olen seda samamoodi teinud. Eelmised korrad, et, ee,
Õpetaja: et mitte nagu hakata, täiesti nullis seda aega kulutama. Võtame põhjana lihtsalt ee komponents madals.
Õpetaja: Ma pakun, et äkki see võiks see olla Ma kord Piilum. Mis siin sees on?
Õpetaja: Tundub täpselt see asi ei ole, et mis vajab.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma kopin selle kõigepealt omale. Desktop ile.
Õpetaja: Mitte desktopile. Ometi Desktop I. Inimesed pole, mis seistel toimub siin. Palju teil ikoone on, No kellel on kooliarvuti? Seal vast väga palju pole.
Õpetaja: Minu naisel on see nagu äärest äärini täis
Õpetaja: paneb. Kogu aeg asjad desktopile ma. Ütlesin Mis sa nagu desktop ile paned? See on lihtsalt täiesti Crazy, Vaata ja. Aga siis ma leian kohe ülesse. Vaata, kõik asjad on sinna Ja mõtlesin, et okei
Õpetaja: mujale.
Õpetaja: Keegi äkki näeb kõrvalt, Vaatab niimoodi. Vau,
Õpetaja: No minu. Naine ei ole muutnud. Ma olen koguaeg öelnud, nagu mis Sa Ei, tee lihtsalt sama. Hästi. Pane lihtsalt dokument alla. Kõik asjad, kui sul on nagu mingid tähtsad dokumendid, asjad Ei, Ei, ei, niimoodi, Kõik asjad kaovad ära, nagu et
Õpetaja: nad on siin.
Õpetaja: Jah, naine leiab kõik asjad üles.
Õpetaja: Ja see on üks suur müsteerium, mis seal kõik Sees on? Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: käib vihma sajuga. Mingi väike käekrott või sadamas
Õpetaja: nagu vau.
Õpetaja: Järgmine. Mõned Paned käe sisse, tirid välja, vaata jänes
Õpetaja: ja ei, Siis lõpuks on juba kuidagi niimoodi. Vaata, et loomulikult nad kuidagi niimoodi. Vaata, et mul on kuidagi see auto range peal. Vaata, aga
Õpetaja: tal Juba nagu ei ole lõpus ruumi. Nagu enam siis ta peab vahepeal God forbi midagi kustutama Hakkama. Seal
Õpetaja: jah, see on päris kole.
Õpetaja: Noh, Ta oleks, ee. Ta oleks ideaalne inimene,
Õpetaja: aga. Aga ta ei ole see. Ta on see inimene, kes on Windowsiga juba harjunud, aga ma ei kujuta ette, mis valemiga muidugi iphone Talle meeldib. Onju, et ma ise olin Androidi inimene. Aga lõpuks kui naine, ja teismeline on iphone ideks. Ma sain, aru et nendega on kuidagi lihtsam. Nagu toimetada, kui
Õpetaja: täna. Ma olen nagu ka enda nagu harjunud, aga minu jaoks iphone on endiselt tegelikult restrictiv. Androidiga oli sul täielik vabadus. Mida sa tahtsid teha, et, ee, nad ikka hullult suruvad oma ekosüsteemi. Vaata ja
Õpetaja: mäklidor üle ei lähe pikka aega, et lapse vaikselt.
Õpetaja: Noh, kõigil on selle jaoks, et tööle saada, kui vajab teist
Õpetaja: ja siis, ee, vanaemalt, ära Vana mulle anti android kätte, Vanaema, nagu kuidas ma nüüd siit helistan?
Õpetaja: Viis, viis. Nii, Kus sul see märk on?
Õpetaja: Ei, tegelikult, Noh,
Õpetaja: ja Ei, see on ee. Kui ma vanasti olen android inimene. Mul üks asi meeldis kõige rohkem.
Õpetaja: Ee, seal oli võimalik Torndaid. Oi, rekordib.
Õpetaja: Seal Oli võimalik legaalseid toredaid ee alla tõmmata.
Õpetaja: Ja see oli nii mugav. Nagu, Vaata, et tõmbasid sealt torenti endale telefoni lihtsalt ja siis panid Telekast panid filmi mängima, Nagu
Õpetaja: kui ei meeldiv onju või? Tõuse isegi püsti. Vaata vedeled seal Niimoodi vaataks mingi filmi telekast.
Õpetaja: Ee, ei, saa.
Õpetaja: Ei saa selle iphone iga. Nad ei ole lubanud ühtegi äppi, mis torenteid alla tõmbab.
Õpetaja: Tegelikult, see on. See on lihtsalt see on arvuti Ja ma ei saa teha sellega, mida ma tahan, aga see on minu oma. Ma olen maksnud selle asja eest ja see tehniliselt on tegelikult, võimalik, et ta piirab ta nagu. Ei, ma ei book nagu. See on asi, mis mulle, Ei, meeldi. Kas ma täna nagu läheks Ee, androidi peale tagasi.
Õpetaja: Jah, ei, ma sellega, ma olen nõus, ma olen nõus. Võibolla kui see võibolla oleks mingi pixelfon, või mis iganes, Kus on minimaalselt seda peale pandud, et ma tahaks nihukest võimalikult nagu native Ee android I. Siis ma oleks juba nõus. Ma olen seda mõelnud
Õpetaja: panna. Mingi asi, onju?
Õpetaja: Kõik maksis
Õpetaja: Nüüd on õnneks muidugi seal. Iphone is on ka läinud nagu selles mõttes paremaks et see, nagu Tasuta kraami on igasugust. Ja. Aga ma. Ma ise tunnen ikkagi, et tegelikult nad on üsna nagu restrictiv, et, noh, ma igapäevaselt enam nagu Nii hullult ei igatse, et eks see inimene harjub
Õpetaja: ümber. Vaata sellega, et on vaja oma tagumik nagu diivani pealt. Ära tõsta, mingi
Õpetaja: läpaka juurde minna, Topsida seal asju. Vaata ja siis minna telefoni juurde tagasi, et saaks midagi vaadata, Onju legaalset. Mis saab internetist leida? Vanasti oli Neil võrguasi ka polnud. Mitte Ip, vaid oli Apple Dog, et terve see kontor kõik on Siis ee. Selle Apple Dog I võrgus, siis on ka Nii et kes oli nagu Windowsi inimene. See nagu oli hädas seal ja. Ja, noh,
Õpetaja: jah, aga nüüd on, Nüüd on selles mõttes mingid asjad juba saab vist saab androidiga pilt. Kas pilte saab vahest telefonist teise? Nagu ini inimese moodi?
Õpetaja: Ee, iphone. Too android või See on endiselt nagu mingi endiselt vä
Õpetaja: täiega. See hakkab. Vot see on nagu. Vaata, see ongi see. Vaata, nad on nagu nii. Vaata, Nad teavadki et seda, et sellega nad hoiavadki sind kinni. Vaata selle kuradi pildivärgiga. Mitte vaid see, et sa paned nagu telefoni telefoni teed. Kuule, Tegin paar pilti ja anna mulle. Vaata,
Õpetaja: kuidas
Õpetaja: ei androidil omavahel saab ilusti, aga. Aga ei saa, ei saa lihtsalt niimoodi, et ee, et kvaliteet ja Whatsapp ist jätab alles. Ja, No ja, aga mis kuradi elu see on? Nagu. Vaata, et teistpidi paned, nagu
Õpetaja: ma panen Nagu selles mõttes ma ütlengi ja siis. Noh, kuidas nad Usa S. Nagu on? See? Vaata, et
Õpetaja: sõnumitel Vaata, mis sa saadad vaata läbi, Vaata siis, kui sul on iphone oma. Seal on Niuke väikene linnukene taga. Kui saatjal on ka iphone, siis sa nagu näed seda
Õpetaja: ja See on nagu see. Vaata, et sa oled sa mingi vaene vend. Vaata, kellel kui messid Vaata, Vaata, ta ei ole linnukesed Või noh, See on igal pool. Lihtsalt Usa S. On see teema nagu.
Õpetaja: No jah, siin on vist see, et ühtepidi tekst on roheline sul on. Sul on kas nagu roti nagu haisu juures. Või oled sa Rich? Vaata, et see on hea. Sellega saab kohaldada maksesüsteeme, et kuhu, kes tuleb selle telefoniga. Oma.
Õpetaja: Ei, no loomulikult. Ega sellel ei olegi Muidugi, mingi. Ma mingi just mingi kõige soodsama iphone kuskilt osta kasutatud ja mul. See Saadan ainult sellega sõnumeid ja kõik mõtlevad. Oi, nüüd see on ikka. Mina Ma pole. Ma ei viitsi isegi saata ikka saadan Läbi Messenger I seal Niikuinii pole seda
Õpetaja: seda värki. Vaata, et ainult nendel Niiöelda on see linnukene. Ma isegi ei ole isegi kunagi märganud, Seda, kes nii on Okei,
Õpetaja: kui see vaene, vaene. Vaata, android. Vaata, tellib endale Uber It ega ta muidu ei telli, kui hint on Nagu kurakas. Vaata, onju, et.
Õpetaja: Ja see rakenduskontrollib seda aku seisu ka veel, et kas sa. Noh, kui sul on akud vähe, siis
Õpetaja: ee, Poole pealt see, et
Õpetaja: Maciga harjub ülikiiresti ära ja ülikiiresti harjub ära. Ja lõpuks kui mul oli tööarvuti, oli ka Max, siis kuidagi mingid Shortcut asjad on palju rohkem käejärge ja käe juures. Mugavam oli
Õpetaja: Noh, otse Seal on mingid asjad on niuksed Subjektiivsed. Ma ise nõustun ka sellega. Vaata, et, ee. Mingid asjad on, ee, tšillid ja
Õpetaja: graafika mälu niimoodi, et ai jaoks sa saad jagada nagu kogu seda mälu, et See on. Nagu
Õpetaja: Kuulge, Davai. Lähme tuleme nüüd tagasi programisteemadele Lõunavaate surub ka varsti peale. Tahame. Tahame täna kindlasti jõuda teha, et saaks ee, kuuel nädalal. Ee, teha. Vaatame, kuidas sellega läheb.
Õpetaja: Ee, panin teile Slaki siis Ee, sõnumi See sama fail. Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: vajutage lihtsalt download ja ta Tuleb Sinna downloads ka osta.
Õpetaja: Pacemodal
Õpetaja: ja siis ega muud midagi, kui lihtsalt teete endal selle
Õpetaja: downloads tausta lahti, vaatate, kus ta tuli
Õpetaja: paned, Võibolla Addate modified järgi. Noh, nüüd ongi see.
Õpetaja: Aa, ma ei ole vajutanud. Vajutame Open Containing Folder.
Õpetaja: Tuli aga ta tuli mul selle ühega Vahet pole. Ma muudan selle. Ära.
Õpetaja: Copy Control C. Intellig jäi lahti
Õpetaja: ja komponentsi alla panema. Komponentsi all peaks kah natukene korda tegema Praegu siin igasugused failid nagu järjest.
Õpetaja: Aga praegu sellega ei viitsi tegeleda. Paneb ühe lihtsalt juurde komponent siia, alla, et lõppkokkuvõttes teil peaks tulema, siis siia juurde. Räägin Dropiga. Vä Kontroller ei peaks ka Töötama ju.
Õpetaja: Vaitsen oma arust.
Õpetaja: Ma pean korra. Pean korra uuesti kopima.
Õpetaja: Control, C, Control, V. No nüüd lubab faili nime. Ma võtan siin korda.
Õpetaja: Päris madal.
Õpetaja: Nii tore, roheline. Sellepärast, et. Ee, uus fail.
Õpetaja: Kui sa mõtled seda, Mul on ka
Õpetaja: nüüd, kuidas see asi töötab. Siis hakkame siit kuskilt ülevalt pihta.
Õpetaja: Esimene kui korra panna see kinni ja keskenduda sellele, mida Mis siit silma kohe paistab?
Õpetaja: Ei, Wave East Open.
Õpetaja: Öeldakse, et, ee. Sellel paste modalil on Niukene Props nagu is open
Õpetaja: ja väike väärtus. Ehk kui seda kaasa ei anta, on Falls
Õpetaja: ehk siis kogu seda mudalit ei näidata.
Õpetaja: Kui on Falls, näidatakse ainult kui on True
Õpetaja: ee, Siin all. Event Modalis Closed.
Õpetaja: Kus me selle mütsi panime? Kas me tõstsime selle ka? Kuhugi ettepoole? Minu meelest
Õpetaja: kuskil ei olnud päri tal Ikka pigem vist oli. Kus meil oli? Palju Mitme. Meil oli? Location Formil oli päris palju mitse. Kus meil on peale Propsi on ikkagi Okei, davai. Nii on siis.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga siin on methods blokk. Nii et, ee,
Õpetaja: ma teeks niimoodi, et ma natuke teeks korda Esiteks, mis siin üldse on? Tagurpidi on see, et templeid on üleval.
Õpetaja: Teeks neid nagu korda, et ee. Paneme template kokku ja script I kokku ja Vahetame nad omavahel ära. Ma ei tea, kas siin õnnestub tulla. Panna see kriip siia juurde. Control Shift ja vajutada nool üles.
Õpetaja: Oi, oi, Oi, enam ei ole.
Õpetaja: Ma just korra lihtsam on. Ma ütlen, et praegu Mul tundub niimoodi, et ma teeks nagu vanaviisi, et
Õpetaja: võtan lihtsalt Selle Cut Iga selle script I osa.
Õpetaja: Panen paar rida ja panen plaati maha.
Õpetaja: Ülevalt Algad ilusti
Õpetaja: Oleks teistpidi proovinud. Jah, okei, no kuidas Iganes peaasi, et saate selle tulemuse, et Script üleval template all. Ee, ja siin sees. Siin see järjekord võib nii jääda, nagu tegelikult on.
Õpetaja: Ee, Näeme, et ee, meetods blokis on siis. Ee, selline meetod, Close. Ja mis ütleb lihtsalt ülesse. Event Modal. Closed.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui me paneme selle korra kinni. Me teame, et meil on siin see props, mis tuleb sisse eas Open
Õpetaja: ja saime aru, et ee, kogu seda madalit, Kas näidatakse või mitte selle peal.
Õpetaja: Nüüd siin tuleb terve rodu. Igast tive, tive ja asju, mis iganes ee tuleb siin ükshaaval.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis on, Ee, sõna otseses mõttes need samad asjad, mis on nagu siin.
Õpetaja: Ahah, ee. Siin on mingisugune osa Ee sellest Cs, mis tegelikult on Kuskil mujal ka.
Õpetaja: Ma ürit üritan vaadata, kas on midagi. Või ei ole
Õpetaja: ma nagu mäletan. Ahah, siin vist on see show. Äkki Ei Mudal Backdrop.
Õpetaja: Varsti vaatame korra. Mul on niuke tunne, et, Ee, siin võib olla mingid Ccs I, mis võibolla on kuskil mujal peidus, millele siin viidatakse, aga aga pole.
Õpetaja: Ma tahaksin teha niimoodi. Et. Ee, vaadake, Rida Kakskümmend kuus. Vähemalt minu ekraanil. Nüüd on kakskümmend kuus
Õpetaja: see slott Aital ja need korra. Kustutame need ära. Kus on slotid? Me tahame seda ise teha. Uuesti
Õpetaja: Mm ee, siin. Selles viimases on Slot on Kahe tag iga. Ja siin keskel on nupp.
Õpetaja: Ma teeks sellega niimoodi, et teeks siia selle Sloti ette natukene ruumi ja tõstaks selle Control Iksiga terve selle rea siit Slotist välja.
Õpetaja: Siis kustutame selle sloti ära. Ma tahaks natuke progemist ka meile jätta.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee, siis H viis Ja Siin selle tag I vahele võiks panna. Ee, mingi pealkiri.
Õpetaja: Teeme niimoodi. Step by step et on mingi pealkiri.
Õpetaja: See koht, kus on Modal Body settiv. Siis on siis on mingi sisu. Näiteks midagi oleks näha, aga need on.
Õpetaja: No seal. Selles futeris on meil, ee, niikuinii Mingi pat on sulgev, mis? Ee, teeb kah midagi? Ee, emiiti tasandil. Aga meil nagu põhimõtteliselt. Kui me nüüd kasutaksime kuskil seda
Õpetaja: ee, komponenti, Siis me midagi visuaalset saame ette. See oli see konks.
Õpetaja: Ahah, õnneks. Ee, praegult ei ole midagi hullu, et kui oled mingi haru peal, Te olete omanimelise haru peal. Suure tõenäosusega. Ee, ütleme New Branch Ta praegult võtab need muudatused kaasa. Kõik mis on siin, Ee, kõik, mis on siin selle all. Vaata, et see nagu liigub praegu niiöelda kaasa,
Õpetaja: et ütleme New Branch.
Õpetaja: Mm, Jah, oota. Ma ruttu. Võtan mingi taaski numbri ka. Sest et madal päriselt tuleb taaskina. Kuskilt sisse
Õpetaja: ongi. Web Kaksteist juba.
Õpetaja: Aa, ei, no aa. Okei. Ma mõtlesin, et ütlesite mulle, See oli hoopis küsimus, on ju? Või arvamine?
Õpetaja: Mõtlesin, et keegi juba vaatas ära, et teeb kaksteist. On See õige, on madalam.
Õpetaja: No ma Otsin ülesse niikuinii. Ma selle taskelt. Võtame. Selle siis korra silme ette ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, tahan
Õpetaja: Chira sse.
Õpetaja: Teilsest ei jäänud ühtegi lahti, et häbid Läksid vahepeal kinni
Õpetaja: Siiralt. Otsin siis Ee Frontend pank.
Õpetaja: Pangaautomaadi lisamine Selle ma tõstan üldse. Ära Ütlen, et tema on omadega komplit.
Õpetaja: Ta on
Õpetaja: on ikka kusjuures. Pangaautomaadi asukoha info vaatamine. Täiendame seda vaadet. Tuleb link. Noh, suurepärane. See Taas sobibki neile ka. Top kaksteist on meie võitja. Ma võin siin ära märkida ka siis selle, et see
Õpetaja: on Ee in progress. Ee, ujub siin Sellel Swimlade il paremal Palju taas ka Polegi tegelikult eriti jäänud. Enam on ju ka. Aga need, mis siin ülejäänud on? Me jätame ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, järgmiseks. Ee, siit kui me tuleme tagasi
Õpetaja: Ei, ole.
Õpetaja: Nii. Ee Teeme. Siis uue haru.
Õpetaja: Ee, veb kaksteist
Õpetaja: nii,
Õpetaja: okei.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on võimalik komitide järgi ka, tulla, eksole? Ehk Sealt see kuskilt. See soov võis tulla. Siis keegi tahab järgi tulla.
Õpetaja: Ei taha, just Lähme edasi.
Õpetaja: Aa, nüüd praegu. Meil on selline komponent olemas, Aga me seda kuskile ei kasuta. No vastavalt taskile. No vaatame korra Taaski ennast ka siis juba natukene sisukamalt. Et Mis me tegema hakkame?
Õpetaja: Andmebaasi mudel ee mängivad siin rollis. Selliseid tabelid neil hetkel väga ei keskendu. See on kogu vaate kohta ka. Muidugi.
Õpetaja: Ee, täiendavaadet. Kaldkriips Atms Panga automaadid. Ee, täiendava asukoha Veerus olevat infot. Nii et asukoha nimi on Link, mille peale saab klõpsata. Link on nähtav. Kõigile olenevalt, Kas Kasutaja on sisse logitud või mitte. Ringi Peale vajutades kuvatakse kasutajale mudalina konkreetse asukoha. Info asukoha. Info mudel näeb välja umbes selline. See pilt on vananenud. Ee, aga siin peaks tik tiktik olema. See mingi sidekriips on ju Mingi jama.
Õpetaja: Madali puhul avaneb eraldi komponent Location info modal Kasutajale kuvatakse asukoha infot eraldi aknakeses, nii et taust on halliks tehtud noh, see on lihtsalt mudeli kontseptsioon. Nüüd andmed tulevad sellisest teenusest
Õpetaja: üksiku Objekti ära toomine
Õpetaja: siin. Tegelikult mõtlen, et äkki teeks ka selle ainusesse. Minu mõte nii oleks kaasa. Tuleb anda Variablina Location Id
Õpetaja: ee ehk Siis Urli läheb kaasa. Vabandust, mitte Urg. Näh, Urli endasse. Rajamuutaja.
Õpetaja: Sulge võiks nuppu vajutada. Suletakse modal.
Õpetaja: Siis on see see madal on eraldi Seisev Ee V. Kolmteist Edit
Õpetaja: funktsionaalsest meile. Okei, selle osa ma võtaks. Maha Ee, seda ei, ole vaja. Seda. Ignoreerime korra praegu see lähenemine. Ma ei taha teha, okei?
Õpetaja: No alustaksime siis kõigepealt sellest, et saaks üldse midagi mingi pildi ette.
Õpetaja: Lähme otsime ülesse. Ee, vaatest.
Õpetaja: View,
Õpetaja: otsime Ülesse, templeid, bloki. Mingid muud asjad võib Praegu Tajutasid korraga kinni panna Üldse
Õpetaja: kogu. Selle Noh, kogu Scripti võib kinni panna. Hetkel meil pole seda vaja. Keskendume sellele.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin. Kus on header pangaautomaadid. Nüüd Tegelikult pole absoluutselt vahe ku. Kus me nüüd selle komponendi esile kutsume?
Õpetaja: Ee sellepärast, et taustal toimetab selline lahendus, et. Ee.
Õpetaja: Vaadake hotell. Meil ju tuleb niimoodi järjest Vaata, et kui sa teed mingisuguse body, sealt tuleb Header. Kõik tulevad järjestikuna ülevalt alla või vasakule. Parem vahet pole, aga nad tulevad järjest.
Õpetaja: Aga modal ju Tegelikult Idee järgi. Lihtsalt tuleb vaatena ekraani ette. Kuidas see taustal saavutatakse, Et kui meil on Ee, kui me mõtleme korraks niimoodi, et meil on, Ee,
Õpetaja: mul on korra mõtlema, Töö on ta lähedas.
Õpetaja: Kui me mõtleme, et meil on klassikaliselt niukene kordinaatteidest.
Õpetaja: Ee, kuidas on selliste Nietzsche, et see ei ole, siis see on vasakule paremale,
Õpetaja: aga nüüd tuleb juurde. Z mis on Z? On
Õpetaja: sügavus, Et teda. Et kui meil praegu siin on mingisugune pilt, näiteks
Õpetaja: Ütleme tema mingi pilt. Ma ei tea, mis siin on peal. Mida iganes ütleme, et tema niiöelda indeks on Ee, üks,
Õpetaja: nii kui me Meie tahaksime teha juurde ühe kasti.
Õpetaja: Ka enda Oleks nagu
Õpetaja: niimoodi. Ja oleks temast nagu pealpool, Sest me saaksime defineerida. Selle kasti ära anda seda X ja Y,
Õpetaja: Et kus ta asub? Nagu külmõttes. Aga me saaksime siit alla anda. Näiteks indeksi. Kaks
Õpetaja: positiivsed asjad tulevad peale, ehk Siis see kassikene varjab sellega hästi ära. On selle peal.
Õpetaja: Kui me tahaksime seda, et oleks selle all, siis võibolla võiks olla vist, ma Ei tea, miinus kaks.
Õpetaja: See on lihtsalt numbrilised väärtused, millega on võimalik siis manipuleerida seda, kuidas asjad nagu teineteise nagu peale olemise mõttes nii öelda kehtivad, et taustal on umbes selline lahendus.
Õpetaja: Umbes või kuidas? See madal toimub,
Õpetaja: et kui pole vahet, kus sa selle koodis selle html I nagu bloki. Nagu kirjutad. Sellepärast see tegelikult tuuakse kogu lehest
Õpetaja: Grammivõõra ettepoole tõstetakse täpselt sinna, paika, kuhu soovitakse. Noh, saab arutada ekraani laiuse, järgi, mis iganes.
Õpetaja: Ei, loomulikult Sa oled ise nagu ei pea manageerima. See on teema. On ju,
Õpetaja: et nüüd, kui ma praegu võtan näiteks selle Kolmi, kus lihtsalt praegu on, siis pangaautomaadid? Noh, korra paneme selle vaate ette ka. Et oleks, nagu võimalik midagi rääkida. Pangaautomaadid
Õpetaja: Pole vahet, Kus ma nüüd selle esile kutsun? No mina kusun. Kutsun selle. Ee, pangaautomaadid. Ja selle tabeli vahepeal. Näed. Või üldse, nagu ma panen, ma Panen ta praegu korraks lihtsalt siia.
Õpetaja: No mis selle komponendi nimi on
Õpetaja: Ee, Kui mina panen siia B ja M, ma kutsun välja selle komponendi.
Õpetaja: Tema nüüd ei tea, kas ma tahan seda ühe tag Iga või kahe tag iga Esialgu teeme ühe tag. Iga. Paneme selle kaldkriipsu ära.
Õpetaja: Hetkel ei peaks midagi juhtuma siin sellepärast, et
Õpetaja: Pacemodal tegelikult ootab, et ta saab sisendina kontrollühik muuta. Dis Open
Õpetaja: vaikimisi on tema väärtus Võime kord samm sammult teha. Vaikimisi, Kui seda ei anta, on tema väike väärtus. Ma võin korra truu panna, aga ma kavatsen selle kohe tagasi panna sest tuli mudal ette
Õpetaja: mingi pealkiri. Mingi sisu sulge. Okei, loomulikult, See peaks olema False, aga ma saangi siis siin. Selles talle öelda, et ee, kool on
Õpetaja: Is Open saab väärtuse
Õpetaja: turu. Siin see kool kuigi muutujast ei tule. Aga kui ma panen niimoodi, siis ta mõtleb, et see on string. Ma ei taha stringi anda. Ma tahan anda päris otse väärtust.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd saame siin kontrollida. Seda. Vaata, et Selles mõttes, et kui ma panen siia False, siis ta loomulikult läheb. Peita
Õpetaja: on nii?
Õpetaja: Vaata mõttes aru, kuidas see, asi töötab ja see, mis ma just rääkisin, ka et ee, see tegelikult visuaalselt lihtsalt tõstetakse esile
Õpetaja: teistest osadest. Ülejäänud osa tehakse halliks.
Õpetaja: Noh, umbes nii
Õpetaja: loomulikult, Css Is on kõike võimalik sättida ja seadistada, et kui tume, on see taust ja ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, sa praegu teed oma rolli. Kas Ta oleks täpselt Center või? Ta on ikka üleval. Mulle endale meeldib pigem üleval. Ma olen proovinud ka seda mängida et pane täpselt keskele, Nagu ka vertikaalselt. Ja vahel läheb nagu see asi kuidagi minu jaoks ikkagi imelikuks. Nagu
Õpetaja: Mulle meeldib ka enda, nii, eriti kui mudal on suurem. See on natuke muidugi maitse asi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on niimoodi, et vaid et sulge nupu asja Mitte midagi ei toimi.
Õpetaja: Its Fine, sul peabki nii olema.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, mida me tahame teha, on, see, et ee praegult on. Siis ära see asi defineeritud niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Et me ei saa talle tegelikult Midagi peale selle
Õpetaja: data Props I midagi kaasa anda.
Õpetaja: Nii, see on ka Fine. Tahan kinni panna hirmsasti. Vaata, ei saa.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd Minu mõte on see, et. Ee. Vajutame nüüd korra. Siin Control set I. Senikaua, kuni see laseb siit üldse jalga.
Õpetaja: Noh, premium on kiri. Kustutame selle ära sellepärast, et nii nagu ma enne rääkisin, siis meie ei hakka tegema niimoodi et me iga Jumala kord, kui me tahame mingit madalit, teha, et siis me teeme ühe uue madali. See modal saab olema modal, mille peale
Õpetaja: teised modalid tulevad. Ehk siis Logout Modal Ja ma ei tea, display info modal, mida iganes,
Õpetaja: et, ee, ma sooviksin.
Õpetaja: No okei, me võime. Me võime kasutada ka, Okei, ma korra Ei, lisa ühte uut kihti. Davai, lähme korra sinna. See Pacemodal tuleb varsti tagasi. Aga. Aga teeme selle siis uuesti kui vaja.
Õpetaja: Tuleme nüüd siia sellesse kohta mingi pealkiri.
Õpetaja: Ee, kus on siin? Ee, see osa
Õpetaja: siin Me tahame teha sellist lahendust, et
Õpetaja: siin oleks üks ee slot, Me kasutame selle entriga. Lööme ära, et me teeme. Tekitame siia pesa, millele on võimalik viidata.
Õpetaja: Ee, Slott Ongi Ee, siis see element, mis Meid Aitab,
Õpetaja: Tab. Iga võib selle ära teha. Ta on koosneb kahest osast.
Õpetaja: See Kas teil tuleb midagi sisse on?
Õpetaja: Ma võin Step by Step teha. Vaata,
Õpetaja: Aa, nüüd ei ole võimalik kuskilt näha. Ikka tuleme siia tagasi, et,
Õpetaja: ee. Paneme korraks siia selle pacemodeli tagasi. Mitte korraks, Vaid nüüd, võibolla natukeseks ajaks. Niiöelda.
Õpetaja: Ee, page modal.
Õpetaja: Ee, ühe taggiga ja paneme selle ja tagasi. Muidu ei ole võimalik kuidagi seda kuvada Nii tuli tagasi, onju?
Õpetaja: Nüüd, mis meid lihtsalt eelkõige siin huvitab, Ongi siis, see, et see slott töötab niimoodi, et meil on võimalik defineerida Mingi pesa ja meil on võimalik siia sisse sisu ka panna. Aa,
Õpetaja: aga see pesa nüüd toimib Selliselt. Et
Õpetaja: juhul, kui me hakkame pöörduma selle pesa peale, Ütleme, et anna sinna pesasse mingi sisu. Siis see osa, mis meil on siin juba ära defineeritud, Eel sees seda ei näidata vaid juba siis see, mida me soovime niiöelda siia kaasa anda. Aga et üldse midagi saaks teha, on niimoodi. Et sellele Slot ile Tuleb anda oma nimi.
Õpetaja: See käib minu meelest vist on name atribuudiga.
Õpetaja: Ma kustutasin ära, enne, onju? Võin Hästi, kergelt vaadata.
Õpetaja: Ee, Download I all. On see fail veel olemas, et. Ee. Kas see Syntax oli? Name On name? Jah, siis ma ei hakka vaatama. Näen name
Õpetaja: atribuut Name on selles mõttes täiesti tavaline. Pigem nagu lausa Html. I Niiöelda atribuut on ju nime saab alati anda mingisugusele
Õpetaja: ee, elemendile ja siis On lihtsalt mõelda pidepunkt välja, et et. Kuidas me edaspidi hakkame selle Slot i poole pöörduma Kuna ta on siin selles titli sees, siis Kõige parem nimi olekski
Õpetaja: täidab.
Õpetaja: Ee, mina olen kasutanud siin. Kui ma kirjutan mingi mitme sõnaga asja.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, kas see täpselt, on Ee, selline või või mis see tava on? Aga Ma pakun, et Camel Case Oleks Niukene. Mõistlik. Asi
Õpetaja: kui, mitmest sõnast nüüd sellel slotil on niiöelda
Õpetaja: nimi olemas, mis tähendab seda, et idee järgi on võimalik seda ee seda modalit niimoodi välja kutsuda,
Õpetaja: et siia selle koha asemele On võimalik ee, anda mingisugune Html sisu.
Õpetaja: Nüüd me läheme tagasi sinna ja me proovime seda asja.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd seda asja nagu proovida, siis Enam ei saa olla see tag ühe tag. Iga.
Õpetaja: Ta peab olema koos oma kahest tag Ist
Õpetaja: ma nüüd peast ei tea, aga ma Pakun, et kui te kustutada need kaks viimast sümbolit ära Shift Enter,
Õpetaja: siis ta teeb selle alguse ja lõpu Niimoodi,
Õpetaja: nüüd me siiamaani oleme ju kutsunud välja igasuguseid City ja Ee. Ja ma ei tea, mida kõike me oleme välja kutsunud. Oleme alati kutsunud. Ühe täagiga, sest siis ei olnud vajadust. Me andsime alla ainult Propsi kujul mingisuguseid andmeid, mida saab atribuudina alati teha. Näete siin samamoodi. Props
Õpetaja: viis Open i peale Kukuma, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga kui me tahame nüüd Html I kirjutada Html ju siin. Kirjutame selles blokis, onju? Nii?
Õpetaja: Ma tahan öelda, näiteks, et sinna Läheb näiteks. Ee, mis? Meil oli Mingi Ph Ee, Ph for Biden.
Õpetaja: Ma korra teen. Lihtsalt See keelumärk oli mingi. Ei, Ph Prohib Projevit
Õpetaja: Ee, see on ühe tagiga. Ütlen, et Size said. On mingi kolmkümmend kaks.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: siis, kui ma nüüd uuesti vaatan seda visuaali, siis me Näeme, et siin selles ei ole haisugi. Mingisugusest ikoonist ei ole. Siin on hoopis,
Õpetaja: kui ma teen selle lahti, midagi ei juhtunud, sest et Üks asi on veel süntaksis puudu.
Õpetaja: Ma pean viitama sellele ja Sellele Slot Ile.
Õpetaja: Kuidas see käib? See käib Ee template.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, kogu visuaalosa on? Templateis, on nii?
Õpetaja: Ma pean viitma templeid elemendile. See on kahe tag. Iga Ee teen niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Paneme selle prohibiti sinna sisse.
Õpetaja: Endiselt veel Midagi ei toimu Sellepärast, et ma pole veel endiselt kuidagi viidanud sellele pesa ala nimega Tajtel.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd me seda just kavatsemegi teha,
Õpetaja: Nüüd See on süntaksi värk, mida peast ei tea, aga, noh, Instagramis, mis meile meeldib. Kõigil
Õpetaja: kirjutada juurde oma sõnumitele ja tekstidele.
Õpetaja: Hashtag olen lahe, on ju, aga siin. On
Õpetaja: Nüüd on need kaks asja omavahel seotud. Mina ütlen, et mina soovin mingit Html I sinna komponendi sisse panna,
Õpetaja: Kus on title Ja, see sisu on selline. Keelumärgi ikoon.
Õpetaja: Tuli.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tahan, näiteks. Noh, random it, mis Me võiksime veel siin panna?
Õpetaja: No paragrahv.
Õpetaja: Oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi. Siis Sinna tuleb selline paragrahv.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tahan siia panna ühe Selectbox I
Õpetaja: Noh, mis? Jah, Okei, läheb olemasoleva asjaga Ära praegu olemasolev asi. Ee, mis meil on Näiteks olemas.
Õpetaja: Oh, ma tean, mis ma teen. Paneme siia
Õpetaja: Location Forum Igavene monster Ee asi.
Õpetaja: No nüüd vist lausa Crash Ib siin, et midagi on puudu. Võibolla liiga keerukas asi. Paneme see Distrop Town
Õpetaja: No Mingi oma Custom I asi.
Õpetaja: Refresh tuli. Kõik linnad. No sisu pole. Seda andmeid pole pärinud. Saate aru,
Õpetaja: Ma saan siia mida iganes panna,
Õpetaja: See annab nüüd ülima paindlikkuse. See annabki nüüd selle, et me saame teha mingisugused komponendid. Mingisuguse disaini, Mingisuguse konkreetse funktsionaalsuse mingi konkreetsete aa visuaalsete elementidega. Aga me saame seda laiendada.
Õpetaja: Saame teha nii, nagu me tahame.
Õpetaja: Ja see on meil valikute küsimus. Vaata, et kõik, mis on nagu siin
Õpetaja: kõik, mis on siin nagu väljaspool neid slotte. See on olemas, et kui ma tahan et see. Aa, kuskil on, No ma panen Näiteks siia, siis ma ei tea, lihtsalt. Aa, see on osa sellest.
Õpetaja: Aga see, mis tuleb. Slot Ist tuleb väljastpoolt.
Õpetaja: Kas saate mõttest aru, Mis, mis, Mis võimekuse see lähenemine annab?
Õpetaja: Jah, siis ei ole pointi, et kui sa saad, kui sa saaksid hakkama lihtsalt Propsiga, siis ee, Pole vaja,
Õpetaja: Siin on nagu, väga spetsiifiliselt see mure, mida ta lahendab, on puhtalt
Õpetaja: Ee, see, et. Ee. Sa saad anda Html I. Juurde. Vaata,
Õpetaja: näiteks kui sa disainid sellelt niimoodi, et see tikel on tegelikult kogu aeg lihtsalt tekst ja sinna juurde ei saa panna mingeid ee, Vahvat ikooni või? Või mida iganes on ju, et kui sul seda paindlikkust ei ole vaja, siis sa teeksid seda kropsiga
Õpetaja: pole vaja,
Õpetaja: aga Kui seal on, Noh, ütleme nii, et siin selles komponendis see title ongi niukene asi, mida tegelikult võiks tegelikult täitsa oma propsiga anda, on ju, et sa nagu midagi muuta nagu ei taha. Otseselt on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, pole või? Või ütlen, et sa. Sa Jah, seal. Ma ei Näe, nagu ma ütlen, et siin saaks niimoodi, nagu näiteks hakkama. Aga võib ka kahtlaseks jätta. Vaata, siin on ka näiteks see asi. Vaata, See on natukene ka mingi niukene. Hägune piir on nagu see. Vaata, et ee,
Õpetaja: tänane vajadus versus tuleviku. Ee, võimalikud vajadused,
Õpetaja: et, ee, alati Kui me midagi programmeerime, siis tegelikult on muidugi alati mõistlik mõelda vaata. Et, ega see mis, täna nagu teeme vaata. Et, täna on ühed vajadused, et kunagi homme. Võibolla on mingid vajadused tulevad juurde. Ee, puhtalt juba puhtalt. Selle selle idee pärast tulebki kirjutada ilusat tarkvara.
Õpetaja: Ma mõtlen Nagu seda, et, ee, ma võin täna teha koodimisega mingisuguse koleduse valmis. Nagu koledus mis töötab
Õpetaja: aga tulevikus See asi hakkab ikkagi arenema elama, Ee, võibolla tuleb sellest mingisugune tarkvara. Mis järgmised kümme aastat midagi teeb
Õpetaja: et? Ee Miks. Miks. Peab kood olema korralik ilus? Loetav, ja struktueeritud Ja nii edasi. Sellepärast, et ta on jätkusuutlik. Ta on skaleeritav.
Õpetaja: Seda on võimalik juurde teha. Asju. Ee, aga ma ütlen, siin on ka Nagu see tuua Konkreetselt see see näide. Vaata, et. Et täna võiksin mõelda, et et siia ei tule ühtegi uut Htm elementi, nagu siia. Sellele Reale. Ja ta paneb Propsiga, Vaata, onju.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga samas kui sa mõtled et ikkagi, tõenäosus on, et äkki ma tahan seda, siis Oleks Mõistlikum see tegelikult arendada niimoodi et, see võimekus on juba tulevikus olemas no. See on nagu nii triviaalne näide vaata. Tulevikus lihtsalt. Muuta Props lahenduse ära ja töötab. Kuigi kui igal pool seda kasutaks, siis peab päris palju kohti muutma. Ikkagi. Vaata, see See argument võibolla võiks jääda. Siin on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga. Aga niimoodi, et sa ei saa ka muidugi alati süsteemi ehitada. Niimoodi, et sa nagu absoluutselt igale poole ehitad Ekstra vaeva ja ekstra koodiga. Mingisugused lahtised otsad
Õpetaja: et, Noh, see ei ole ka mõistlik jälle vaata. Kui, sa eriti kus, tekitab mingi abstraktsiooni tekitab. Vaata hästi palju selliseid liikuvaid osasid, et tegelikult pole vaja. Ütleme niimoodi, et sa teed asjad ülidünaamiliselt. Paned mingisuguse asja, nagu kokku
Õpetaja: aga tegelikult Ta jääbki ühte täpselt sama staffi nagu näitama. Milleks siis see abstraktsioon? Vaata, nagu tohutult laiali mingi. No ma olen. Noh, see vahel võib juhtuda. Vaata, ma võin öelda ka Näiteks kui Eesti energias me töötasime. Meil tuli üks uus seeniori arendaja tuli tiimi Mingi hetk.
Õpetaja: Ee, Tüüp meil oli üks uus projekt. Ee, projekt. Ma ei usu, et seda Ma ei taha uskuda, et see,
Õpetaja: ee, isegi Springbuat ei kasutanud Vanilja jaama nagu tule taevas Appi.
Õpetaja: Ee, oh, jah, seal oli üks vend, kes hakkas nagu põhimõtteliselt mõtlema. Välja vaata ise leiutama seda sama, asja, mis on Springbudis juba olemas. Ehk andmebaasi? Hästi, mõnus mugav käitlemine koodi tasandil. Küsi andmeid, päri andmeid. Kuidagi et ei, kirjuta Sql I
Õpetaja: tuli mingi vend. Põhimõtteliselt, kes nagu ütles, hakkas mõtlema niukest asja, et
Õpetaja: mõtlesin sellise süsteemi välja nagu hästi funktsionaalne programmeerimine, nagu Täiesti Crazy, milleks Miksida seda, et ta hakkas nagu mõtlema nagu välja mingit oma niiöelda meetodeid ja koodi asju, mis võimaldaks andmebaasist pärida ja sisestada andmeid kuidagi mugavalt,
Õpetaja: Aga see on tohutu atraktsioon. Nagu. Vaata, kui kuidas. Ainult tema teadis, kuidas see asi taustal üldse toimus. Teised pidid õppima seda kasutama, Vaata, on ju.
Õpetaja: Ee, et. Noh, siin on samamoodi asi. Vaata, et kui sa ürit teed nagu mingisuguse asja, mis on nagu väga niukene abstraktne. Vaata väga mitmest liikuvas komponendist Niimoodi kuidagi töötab, et anna ainult mingi sisendi asju. Siis ongi see. Ee, et kas on vajalik. Kas Kas on vajalik? Vaata on ju,
Õpetaja: et alati saab ju tegelikult tulevikus ringi muuta. Täna on nagu üsna staatiline. Homme teen ära, aga muidugi, See ei tähenda seda, et sa võiks sellele mõelda.
Õpetaja: Ikkagi mõtlema peab, sest on kohad. Vaata, kus on mõistlik nagu, jätta nagu mingid otsad lahti ja mõelda mingi dünaamilus. Sest et sa pead tõenäoliseks. Sa pead tõenäoliseks seda, et see tuleb,
Õpetaja: et see tuleb nagu pigem
Õpetaja: võibolla see ei ole sada protsenti. Aga sa nagu pead nagu seda Üsna Tõenäoliselt, siis sa võid juba teha niiöelda eos nagu neid otsuseid ja, ee, teha mingit dünaamilisust Ja asja. Vaata juba varasemas etapis.
Õpetaja: See on Niukene. Jah, See on ka väike tunnetuse Küsimus ka on ju, et, ee, et. Noh, et selles mõttes, et ma. Ma toon näite näiteks mida? Nagu mingil põhjusel ikkagi ei tohi. Teha. Ee, selles mõttes et oli Nagu Selline taaskvaate, mis koosnes mitmest jupist. Aga ta tegelikult moodustas üldse terviku.
Õpetaja: Ma teadsin neid taaske. Taaskid oli minu käes niiöelda mingi vähemalt Paar tükki nendest olid on ju
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma tegin mingisugust ühte taaski, siis ma tegin ühe taski raames ühte juppi sellest nagu mingisugusest lahendusest. Ja ma tegin seal tegelikult juba natukene. Ette Vaata asju, mis tulevad järgmisest
Õpetaja: Ja ma sain selle tagant Põhimõtteliselt ütlesid vaata, et et Kuule, see värk ei ole nagu selle taaski sisu.
Õpetaja: See on järgmised. Sa nagu teise taski sisu. Vaata, mis sa natukene juba siin tahad, teha, on ju? Ma ütlesin. No jah, Aga ma. Ju.
Õpetaja: Kohe, kui ma panen punkti sellele peale, siis ma ju võtan järgmise asja. Vaata onju? Ma teen selle ära, et ma nagu jätkan niikuinii. Sellest võtame aru, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga ütles et. Jaa, aga vaata aga tegelikult, noh, See on natukene niukene liiga värk, nagu justkui tunduks. Vaata, onju? Aga näed, Aga taask seda Tegelikult ei ütle, et sa pead tegema ja Kui Testija võtab selle ette kui võtab selle ette, siis ta vaatab seda taski vastu. Vaata,
Õpetaja: et sa. Tegelikult, sa ei lä, sa sa Lähed nagu täie natuke. Arutasime seda ennem ka. Vaata, et kui palju on nagu arendajal. Näiteks mingi vaba voli. Vaata, nagu ise võtta nagu mingid vastu otsuseid ja teha mingeid asju. Vaata, et, noh, tegelikult, sellises Coop is ei ole. Vaata, on ju, et kui ikkagi taaski ütleb, Mida, Mis, on see süsteemi muudatus? Siis see tegelikult niimoodi peaks minema. Olukord oleks täiesti erinev. Loomulikult, kui oleks näiteks mingi kahe kolme mehe,
Õpetaja: Mingi start up. Vaata, nagu
Õpetaja: vahet pole, me peame ruttu Live I jõudma. Raha peab tulema. Me sureme ära, muidu põhimõtteliselt, onju Seal on Savi.
Õpetaja: Ee, Aga nagu kuskil suures. Selles ei ole. Vaata et siis, on. See võib siin see ala. Vaata, et sa üritad teha mingisugust koodi. Ja sa tekitad sinna tegelikult mingisuguse ekstra kihi ja mingi abstraktsiooni.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt sellepärast, ee, et sa nagu mõtled, et äkki tulevikus või midagi Taolist ei ole õigustatud.
Õpetaja: Kuid kui sa kunagi ei realiseeru, Sa tekitasid abstraktsiooni täiesti mõttetult,
Õpetaja: milleks keegi tuleb. Kunagi peab seal koodis midagi parandama, tegema Mida iganes. Vaata natuke juurde, tegema. Midagi taolist. Tal on keerulisem aru saada, kui seal on abstraktsiooni sees.
Õpetaja: Kuskil midagi toimub vaata, ja Sa pead ise selle pildi peas kokku panema.
Õpetaja: Aa, see ei ole nagu mingi mõnus tegevus. Ee, et sellises mõttes nagu Code Reviews võiks vabalt tagasi Põrgata see. Vaata, et sa tegid selle keerulisemalt, kui see tegelikult peaks olema. Vaata, pole vaja ja. Aga äkki kunagi. No jah, Kui see äkki tuleb, teeme ümber
Õpetaja: Äkki tuleb,
Õpetaja: et siin oleks nagu mõlemat. Pidi. Võiks mõelda. Vaata, et kas see title peaks. Olema Slot Või Props. Vaata, onju. Noh, Meie teeme teda siis Slotina lihtsalt saaks harjutada.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui see üks lot on valmis, noh, siis ongi see, Vaata, et see osa siin on Heeder osa. Vaadake selle Glassi nime järgi on näha Heeder Ja mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Mm nüüd järgmisena,
Õpetaja: mis jääb, sellest. Oota, väga huvitav. Ee, see nupp on kuidagi. Aa by the way näete. Seda nuppu close,
Õpetaja: Ja? Siin on nupp sulge.
Õpetaja: Close Sulge, Korraks. Mul tekitas segadust, et mis asja juba on. Body juba on Patoni osa Vaata, et Kuule pole. Pole see headeri osa nagu ära lõppenud. Miks siin Headeri sees on? Button?
Õpetaja: See on see, kui võtta stiililt ära. See see äkki vä.
Õpetaja: Noh, siin on see nupp annab, Aga on stiilinupp.
Õpetaja: Sellist Risti saate igalt poolt otsida. Saate sellise
Õpetaja: tee. Üks div või patt, onju? Pane Saate kohe niukse asja. No näiteks Alertile saaks juurde panna. Näed Alerti. Tahad eest Ära saada? Vaata sega mind,
Õpetaja: mida iganes. Okei?
Õpetaja: Ee, tuleb siis see body mingi sisu.
Õpetaja: Noh, Teeme siia samamoodi.
Õpetaja: Vot
Õpetaja: sa ei pea isegi kaherealiseks tegema. Siis sa niikuinii midagi ei tule.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt name parameeter.
Õpetaja: Noh, Body äkki siis võiks ka olla.
Õpetaja: Ja, noh, saab kohe proovida ka
Õpetaja: lihtsalt korra dubleerida. Lihtsalt seda või? Noh, okei, teeme uuesti. Lihtsalt Ee, templeid taeb
Õpetaja: võibolla siit See City Strop Down. Lihtsalt siia sisse panna,
Õpetaja: Aga tulla öelda siis ka jälle Hashtagiga. Vaadake, ta pakub neid asju, mida ta näeb.
Õpetaja: No See on idea. Loomulikult, onju mõistab seda, asja, et nad on seotud. Nüüd on, niimoodi et see ikoon on seal Titlys ja on siis
Õpetaja: Kõik linnad.
Õpetaja: Noh, jällegi mingid laiused asjad. Vaata, on ju Okei, No seda peab siis ee, manageerima.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma tahaksin siia laios siis Ma tahaks seda Row ide Collide süsteemi ja Coll I lihtsalt piirata.
Õpetaja: Näiteks poodi ei olekski potentsiaalselt siuke osa, Vaata, kus tahad tegelikult nagu Ee, hoida nagu seda stiili.
Õpetaja: Aga praegu sellest Dropdown ist. Meile piisab, et näha lihtsalt et see tõesti nii on Nii, lähme tagasi. Sinna.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd siin on näiteks juba esimene koht, kus on valikute küsimus.
Õpetaja: Kui sa juba näed ette, et absoluutselt igal madalil ee, saad nagu Sulg ee Tahaksid teha et on nupp Sulge,
Õpetaja: et. Noh, pane kinni. Ma tahan
Õpetaja: Siis see võiks olla nagu selles mõttes osa sellest plotsist Ja mitte osa sellest. Slot, ist, kui tahaksid. Nii,
Õpetaja: vaata, küsimus on see. Vaata, kas iga kord hakkad uuesti seal, kus teed implementatsiooni. Vaata, Kas iga kord, kui ma hakkan kutsuma välja nagu seda klotsi
Õpetaja: siis kas ee.
Õpetaja: Kas ma kirjutan selle uuesti või mitte? Et See, vahe Tulebki lihtsalt sellest, et, noh. Slot Zlotiga. Jah,
Õpetaja: see oli päriselt ka kogemata.
Õpetaja: Nii, Slot.
Õpetaja: Ee. Tahtsin siia hashtag I panna, Loll nii võrdub
Õpetaja: Ja, no võiks panna nagu Title Body futer. Aga mina panen mind nagu kuidagi. Kõnetab see rohkem.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd on niimoodi, et see patt on
Õpetaja: seda sulgepatonit Näidatakse, vaata et ta. Me ei ole veel selle sloti poole pöördunud,
Õpetaja: kui me oleme hästi natukene Niukene prügikasti kaup, me Teeme pärast nagu veits. Korrektsemalt Seda praegu lihtsalt harjutame. Teeme selle
Õpetaja: templeid. On resistenter Ee, templeid ja siia Hashtag Ee buttons.
Õpetaja: No ma teen Näiteks ühe Batoni.
Õpetaja: Ee, Button Submit.
Õpetaja: Ma mingit sisu ei pane. Ma teen kavalalt. Ma lihtsalt demomise mõttes panen. Class,
Õpetaja: Mis asi oli Ptn Close on ju?
Õpetaja: Peaks tulema mingi ristikene juurde. Siia kuskile tuli.
Õpetaja: Nii, Äge.
Õpetaja: Nii. Ee. Nüüd on vaja aru. Siis saada sellest, et. Ee, Vaadake, kui me vaatame seda uuesti.
Õpetaja: Mis vahe on? Ee, siin selle Slot I osas,
Õpetaja: et. Kas ta on?
Õpetaja: Ma korra tõstan? Ta jääks Üks niimoodi siit. Kas ta on siin või siin?
Õpetaja: Mis vahe on? Visuaalis
Õpetaja: ja kumb on vasakaga. Kumb on paremal. Ehk kui mina ütlen, et selle Sloti sisu on üleval, siis siin ta rehkendub, et on vasakul, on ju? Kui ma ütlen, et see Sloti sisu on peale seda Patonit. Mis on osa sellest klotsi? Sisu on vastupidi. Saate. Ma üldiselt aru
Õpetaja: muud ei teagi
Õpetaja: ja üldse siis ongi see sama küsimus. Vaata, et kas see. Kas see patt on nagu on niimoodi, et
Õpetaja: ta justkui vaikimisi on.
Õpetaja: Kui ühtegi Patonit. Ee, ei defineeri, mis läks Tuksi korra.
Õpetaja: Ma korra võtan Control Setiga tagasi. Võiks olla ikkagi.
Õpetaja: Aa, okei, ee, no praegu. Ta käitus täpselt nii, nagu pidi. Ma panen korra selle sulge nupu siia Vaata, sisse. Ei näinud seda, aga see on täielik loomulik. Miks, sellepärast, et
Õpetaja: ta teeb täpselt seda, kuidas ta Käituma peab.
Õpetaja: See on meie väike väärtus. Juhul, kui et sulge nuppu on. Alati, kui ühtegi muud nuppu ei lisata. No näiteks on mingisugune Informatiivne aken. Noh, räägime näiteks sellest samast lahendusest. Kuskil on mingi Küsimärk
Õpetaja: on ju nagu et on mingisugune kast, mida vaja täita. Mida iganes On mingi küsimärk? Inimene läheb sinna. Peale Hooverdades muutub see näpuks. Sa saad klikkida Klikid peale, tuleb lahti. Lihtsalt ee, modal ja ütleb sulle. Vaata, on ju et. Ee, siia kasti. Vaata, kirjuta mingit niukest asja on ju, et siin on mingi niuke värk.
Õpetaja: Aa, okei, okei, Kas Siin on mingit nuppu. Nagu muud peale Close.
Õpetaja: Noh, ta on lihtsalt informatiivne. Siin ei saa midagi teha. Ta lihtsalt ütleb et ole teadlik
Õpetaja: siin, nagu ma ei tea, teha sellist informatsiooni. Siis sellisel juhul meil oleks niimoodi, et me ei soovi seda
Õpetaja: Seda Patonit ma korra kommenteerin välja, et
Õpetaja: me ei sõida sellest üle. See tähendab, seda, et kui sisu ei anna, siis ongi siuke nupp olemas ja ta siis kohe toimiks ja töötaks korrektselt, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga meil on alati see võimalus. Et. Oot Oot. Aga ei, ma ikka. Tahan sõita üle millegiga. Vaata, on? Ju
Õpetaja: Panen siia ruttu. Lihtsalt ühe platoni.
Õpetaja: Ma panen pattu. Ma teen lihtsalt mingi punase nupu. Lihtsalt siin mingi Ei, ei lisa, midagi Mida iganes ei saa midagi, las ta isegi olla seal. Old School välimus. Aga vahet pole,
Õpetaja: et see, mis on selle Slot i sees.
Õpetaja: Kui midagi ei anta,
Õpetaja: siis ta jääb alles. Kui see Slot niiöelda kutsutakse välja, et tahan midagi anda, siis sõidetakse üle ja te saate siis ise niiöelda nagu oma disainis otsustada. Vaata, et milline teil see komponent on. Vaata, nagu, et mida on võimalik natukene muuta, mis on osa, mis on ülekirjutatav osa ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma tahaksin praegu nüüd siin kahte nuppu vaata lisa midagi ja tahaksin ka Close nuppu Noh, siis ma pean selle siia tegema, et kui see disain on selliselt tehtud, et ta sõidab juba üle, siis kõik see, mis on, See on on ju,
Õpetaja: et siis ma pean siia veel ühe patani tegema. Ise ütleme, Pattan ja panen. Ee, sulge ja ma panen ta Lihtsalt koleda disainiga,
Õpetaja: et see on nagu valikute küsimus. Lihtsalt, et saate nagu mingi mängumaa Sloti sisse saab panna väike väärtus, et neid asju, Seni seda seda disaini näidatakse. Senikaua, kuni keegi Slot iga üle ei sõida sellest,
Õpetaja: et see annab nagu päris päris hea paindlikkuse. Anna
Õpetaja: nii, Ee, ma arvan, et mingisuguse idee saite kätte. Võibolla nüüd oleks paras hetk teha. Lõuna sobib teile
Õpetaja: Ja siis pärast seda sõidame siit samast kohast edasi
Õpetaja: ja hakkame seda asja natuke timmima.
Õpetaja: Ee, veb kaksteist. Ee, Working progress üks. Ja kui Push in ära no teeme siis täistunnil Tagasi on ju
Õpetaja: või? Viis minutit enne seda. Ükstuspuha.
Õpetaja: Kuidas tulete klassiruumi?
Õpetaja: Tule, panen rekordi ka stoppi. See tähendab seda, et ee, pärast peab tingimata panema käima.